the parents glenn and gary were the sons
and when they were in college i would go
in there in high school i was like a
junior and mrs ashman said coco stock up
the use because we're all sold i mean
you whose would sell by 10 o'clock they
put 100 use in that [ __ ] case but it
was all daily it was all day the
teachers were busy all day the school
got so pissed that they told people that
you weren't allowed to leave the school
for lunch now why because they want the
cafeteria to make money
so
all the food distribution in north
jersey is handled by a lot of people you
don't want no [ __ ] problems with you
know what i mean all right so people
stay and eat the god damn
so you would suspend us but mr hash
would go [ __ ] that go in the back i'm
not gonna let him go in the back
but if i say hey guys that means run out
the back door so for a year until they
moved that law we would sit in the back
of hash ways and delete the [ __ ]
thing while the school teachers were in
front looking for it
and the chewing office is the whole
thing
[ __ ] hysterical
sandwich there was no goddamn good place
in my [ __ ] town i got no good stories
you know you know we had fried bologna
sandwiches like oh my god you hear that
that's your grandma rolling off and i
went back in 99 just flipping right in
the grave my god when i went back in 93
i stayed with my buddy and see caucus
name mike ronnie and down the block from
his house was a [ __ ] deli that i'll
put it up against any deli ever
but their [ __ ] claim to fame was they
had peppers
stuffed
with mozzarella sauce
oh my god with mozelle cheese a little
sauce and i going in the morning just
the green peppers just a [ __ ] like a
pepper and you and it's a spicy pepper
it was like that peppercini so you had
to get three of them
and a sandwich so you could eat the
pepper while you're eating the [ __ ]
sandwich that type of old school deli
you have different types of delis but
that was right what the [ __ ] three fat
guys gotta talk about food for now
because we're we're all stoned it sounds
great but it's crazy
what today signifies in the catholic
religion and a lot of other religions
also i mean our our good friend george
got uh rest his mom assault uh she's
passed this year and you know it's it's
hard man my uncle jim passed this year
it's hard you know you see people at the
end of their life that cancer is a
miserable miserable thing man i mean it
is a horrible way to pass
you know yeah i'd rather get slammed
into a sign on the five and break that
[ __ ] i'd say god forbid but hey i'd
rather take that than
that stuff you know what i mean so it
was it was just fun going to church it
really was i went by myself with no
pressure on my wife and the kid i didn't
want them there
i just wanted to go because they we did
that church over saint bartholomew they
redid it over so i just went in there 7
15.
i'll tell you what man it just brought
back a lot of [ __ ] memory like that's
what happens in church for me now when i
go to church i look at the 12 stations
of the cross and it's like a [ __ ]
acid trip man yeah i just go back into
sections
and i remember i was thinking about my
godfather one of the worst things i ever
did in my life was [ __ ] my godfather
after church i went home and i tried to
find them
on facebook yeah he's those [ __ ]
cubans don't go on facebook he lives in
the keys
i wanted to really when i was a kid my
god
it's amazi what has happened
did you see mad max yes okay
the question that [ __ ] me in that
movie is who killed the world
oh yeah man keep asking who killed the
world you know what man they've killed
the [ __ ] world already the world is
half dead and we don't even know no it's
more than happening treating this week i
saw a trick-or-treat now
there's no kids on the day time i mean
these are great areas the chickens eat i
didn't get one at night i saw kids but
they they're confined the parents put
the fear of god into these kids yeah you
know friday night i went to this trunk
or treat
you know what man did mercy have a great
time
[ __ ] yeah she had a great time
you know did i have a great time [ __ ]
yeah watching her and watching the kids
and watching my wife i dressed up i put
[ __ ] in my mouth and she kept saying no
thank you daddy
take the [ __ ] fangs out of your mouth
no thank you daddy and she would keep
tugging my cape no thank you daddy
it was the cutest [ __ ] thing i i went
in and i had a great time we got that 5
30. the dinner they made us was you know
not bad it was a cheeseburger with
macaroni salad it was a barbecue
i enjoyed it and then i watched her play
ball with other kids and i could tell
that we're halfway there we're okay we
got an okay kid the ball hit her in the
face three times she didn't cry some
little boy dressed up as captain america
got hit once he wouldn't stop crying
but when the kids left to eat she didn't
want to eat so she stayed with me
she goes daddy come here and i started
playing ball with us so when kids came
over to play she was like
it's being him now
and she was going [ __ ] nuts that was
the only problem we had all night
everything was great but back to trunk
or treat it's like a cars get together
it's like a beautiful car show and they
back up and they open their trunks and
they hand kids and they sit in front of
the trunks with disguises
and i'll tell you what is it like a low
rider club and or hot rods or stuff no
no no it was just all these [ __ ]
studio city people oh yeah you know
whatever they are i don't know what
person i didn't talk to one i talked to
maybe two parents in the principal man
you know i've gone i've done that same
thing with uh uh
mexican car clubs bro they are the
nicest that that they had they had a
whole goat cooking okay i mean it was
the real deal old ladies was making
tortillas okay they was handing out good
candies and stuff like that having a
blast they had a band a salsa band it
was on man i'm telling you it's for kids
this was for [ __ ] kids yeah that's it
was for kids too yeah there's no [ __ ]
salsa man when there's kids this is
[ __ ] white
oh white kids no this is white kids
there's no salsa man there's no beatles
they're barely walking around want to
hear about white people
so these [ __ ] i mean the most
interesting thing in the world was i
looked at my wife at one point i go
what the [ __ ] is this i know like i
almost had a nervous breakdown like what
the [ __ ] is this is like puerto rican
[ __ ]
but i go this is what
this is what we have now
the parents scare the kids
and you know let's let's get together
let's put them all together when i was a
kid you one parent went out everybody
held hands and you [ __ ] knocked down
doors and you yelled and
you know saturday night i didn't see
people till eight o'clock at night how
much pot do i smoke on my balcony at
night people a lot tons i'm standing out
there and i was scared to smoke and my
kids are to walk up on me after 30
minutes nobody said nothing every once
in a while i'd see
three kids and a parent
but the 80 90 kids i used to run with 80
[ __ ] kids on thanksgiving yeah you
ran 80 deep on thanksgiving running
i didn't see that
and it's just and i know
they found needles and [ __ ] every year
some [ __ ] dummy in pittsburgh sticks
hypodermic needles and [ __ ] chocolate
and all this [ __ ] man that's why i meant
i i tell all my kids uh hey
daddy has to inspect all of your candy i
need a bite out of all this [ __ ]
that's what i did on saturday night
friday night dawg i got so high after
trunk or treat
i went home and she came home with a bag
of candy and i kept sitting there and i
started talking to me like cocaine like
a little yeah
and you have one reese's oh you're
[ __ ] then you're [ __ ]
will [ __ ] put you
that's my world that's my world since
i've been [ __ ] fine
since i came from cube i discovered
swedish fish the red ones are the
multicolored ones listen the red ones
they only come in one color sweeter fish
that's it the ones the 7-eleven in the
back that's the only one i eat all those
invitations and skinny worms and [ __ ]
shove those up your mother's ass i don't
need none of that [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
swedish [ __ ] fish fan since day one
when i was a kid i'd buy them by the box
oh they said i'd get a brown bag and i'd
stick my hand and put them in and put
them in my pocket that's how there was
something when i was put them in your
pocket in a bag and a brown bag you get
there's a baby
i bought the box from the wholesaler oh
really sixth grade i used to know where
to buy the box
there was a [ __ ] wholesaler for candy
when i was a kid on tunnel
and i would go down there i wouldn't
tell nobody
i wouldn't tell nobody i go down in i
get a box of swedish fish and i get a
box of a thing called devil gump what's
that devil gum way before [ __ ] these
other
gum thieves thought about big red
see big red with who makes big red
regularly wrinkly see wrigley
they bumped devil gum when i was a kid
devil gum was cinnamon but it was hot
like if you ate three slices
your [ __ ] was gonna be on fire though
that's what mexicans give their kids
well then they can't you know we had
atomic fireballs that's all we had right
with fireballs but you also
that's why your asshole's on fire my
asshole's not on fire because of that
i'm telling you i've been swallowing gum
since day one so my body knows how to
process it now
see if you start swallowing gum when you
ate then you're [ __ ] up i've been
swallowing gum since day one content
doctor please email joey and do what was
he gonna say to me i've seen him learn
how to listen i have pulled the gum out
of my [ __ ] i have pulled little
pieces of gum sometimes that don't get
processed yeah out of the hair
or sometimes you're gonna pull the [ __ ]
out and you can hear the gum going
it's like getting
ah
you can hear my gum it's like
let me tell you what
have joey when he gets one of them good
ass zits above his [ __ ] to come and
pop it like a foot and a half away from
you so you hear it okay he did that in
my [ __ ] apartment after he drank all
my goddamn orange juice all right he
drank a whole [ __ ] bag of orange
juice in ten minutes and then proceeded
to pop a zit on it
yes and no not on his [ __ ] in the
crack right above it so to get any
pressure behind it he had to take those
big ass fingers
i used to travel by bus to a lot of gigs
was my sponsor for a long time the dewey
express the joey express i would get on
that [ __ ] downtown bus to el paso and
i'd drop you off and pick you up the
longest bus ride i did was new york city
to dallas that was the longest because i
had nothing going on and i'm gonna go to
all the way to kennedy and drop 200 when
i can i'm here right here and i can pay
the express for 48 dollars i looked at
just to see just to get to boston it's
like only like two and a half days for
like 100 bucks
so i would never i mean if i'm just
saying if i had to
you'll never have to man i travel by bus
because i own one
get a king-sized bed don't do that i
could never set up i could never sit
like that but you guys ought to jump on
the bus sometime and we do this church
at other parts of the country yeah
the bus it will be here uh
to
tonight it'll get in tonight from
tennessee and um and then uh we're here
we're gonna be driving they're gonna be
driving around on wednesday and every
tuesday and wednesday and uh and then we
go north uh to do
do some gig i don't know where it is to
be honest with you i don't look at my
channel
no [ __ ] a fool fighter you guys would
kill each other you guys
before you got to the first rest stop
you're you're [ __ ] we would hot box
that bus
it would be just look bro
look lee shut the [ __ ] up okay me and
coco have lived in
an apartment smaller than this [ __ ]
studio okay and we were we left our
asses off and when the doors were open
and the windows were open because it was
so [ __ ] hot and we couldn't hardly go
to sleep because it was noisy as [ __ ] we
put on joey medina five minutes sleepy
time wake up throw cakes for jesus
making biscuits and i had him on the
floor of futon okay and john wesley john
wesling on the floor and jody ferdig on
the bed yeah it was crazy we were we
were in it to win it this was team us
1440. you don't even understand kill
ourselves we're brothers are you kidding
me well not literally i'm just saying
like you'll put something on the tv that
he doesn't want or he'll start i got
five [ __ ] tv
five [ __ ] tvs on that goddamn bus
pick what channel you won't play
i got it how many bedrooms on the bus
i've got i've got a king-sized back
bedroom that's uh that pops out okay and
then the living room pops out and then
there's three bunks it's got a uh two
bathrooms and a shower on it and
um i've got i think there's like six
air conditioners on it so if we go
someplace where it's hot like i went to
bonnaroo this summer and everybody all
these dirty white people are out there
when it's a hundred and [ __ ] 20
degrees of dirt [ __ ] you i took three
showers a day i was the sweetest smelly
[ __ ] out there people were like
they thought i was for real or something
i was smelling so good okay i was doing
it jack it was awesome everybody's boo
hoo and it's hot yeah me too i'm gonna
go make a [ __ ] margarita in my bus
take a shower and smoke a bone [ __ ] you
i hate that band okay it was awesome it
was so great but that's how we gotta go
dude we gotta go on the [ __ ] bus
all right your babies would go bananas
in that bus
your baby would love that [ __ ] button
that's a monster
i can't understand that no it just ain't
an expired viking what do you think will
happen
get stuck in that gun you know what
happened
what happened they're listening yeah
right
tell me what [ __ ] happened what
happened poppy a couple weeks ago i went
swimming
in toledo
and i got in the [ __ ] plane the next
day i got an ear infection right oh my
god and i was sitting there and i tell
you man
i i'm you know when you work out and
you're heavy you have to take a leave
sometimes or the other one
uh the other one
no no no
no no no no the other one there's a lot
of an advil okay that's all that works
for at this point for big guys when you
go to jiu-jitsu dude i'm past that yeah
and you get slammed on your back when
you go home and you eat your lunch first
thing you do is take an advil especially
you have to train the next day really
i've never had it you got to do all that
[ __ ] lee cause it lowers the
inflammation you gotta eat [ __ ] uh
like smoking weed eating weed actually
takes away the inflammatory from your
[ __ ] thing you see the google today
anybody see the front page of uh no
yahoo today
more people turn to medical marijuana
prescriptions to them
prescriptions are down prescriptions are
going down man yeah yeah the opiates are
going down
yeah the benzos are going down listen
i'm telling you as your brother
you [ __ ] go
and you work out with any problem those
savages down there at night and you walk
home you can't move oh yeah i'm sure
i'll do an experiment with the
[ __ ] i will experiment i will
give you in the leave one night
and a week later we'll do it again and
i'll give you a chunk of real hash and
you eat that hash and you call me
tomorrow and you tell me which day makes
you feel like that's a bruce lee for
soreness
nobody knew why he was eating marijuana
40 years ago danny de santo said it out
of hegan thing genius that's why he was
eating marijuana because he knew that a
leave will kill you
yeah a leave an adventure
he'll eat your [ __ ] liver you got to
drink gallons of water if you're taking
a leave you got to drink [ __ ] water
throughout the daytime that's why i
don't take them at night i take them
when i get home from jiu jitsu bam so
i'm not
or kettlebells i'm not sure an hour
later whatever the [ __ ] i do when you
saw sometimes you get saw from flying
dude i just wiped the [ __ ] off
[ __ ] man first of all
six hour flight lee you're [ __ ] okay
all right yeah okay you you you fly and
your connection
dallas got bumped so now you're in
[ __ ] chicago and you land at b 32 and
yours is uh next flight is h17
15 [ __ ] minutes and chicago the
[ __ ] terminals are so close together
there's no room for a [ __ ] for a
[ __ ] one of them chairs you give 20
to a black guy with a golf cart no you
gotta [ __ ] hump it dude you gotta
[ __ ] rock a rock and then you're
hungry oh you're [ __ ] hungry you
gotta eat there's nobody sometimes i
take
out the one night with my ear infection
i go you know what somebody gave me
these two vikings and he told me when he
gave him something expired i'm gonna
throw them away i said i don't give a
[ __ ] give me two because i know i'll
need them one night it's not like i eat
them that night with the ear infection i
popped that viking and i gotta tell you
something i got [ __ ] up on that couch
dog i liked it
i [ __ ] smoked a hit and i [ __ ]
went to bed i got up like brand new the
next day my ear hurt a little bit but it
didn't hurt as much as i heard he gave
me tools and i said the other one fell
out of the bag that was it right there
oh my god that was the one i just found
it i thought it fell out of the [ __ ]
bag
i think i like those pills too much i
don't do them i don't i don't [ __ ] with
none of them no more i like
i like uh i like them too much i like
the feeling of
when i'm on the road
yeah that's where i like
uh something to sleep i have sleeping
pills to prescribe to me me too because
i can't sleep you need sleeping pills
with weed yeah i can't i could fall
asleep right now you're not us
when i get up at five on the right titty
baby when i get up on thursday morning
and i gotta go do a radio right and i
get up and it's six
right like they're picking me up at 7
30. okay so i don't want to just get up
at seven on a rush i want to get up i
want to relax i want to read the paper i
want to eat a good breakfast i want to
write a little bit i want to slow down
stretch a little stretch a little i'll
get up let's take a shot and do all that
[ __ ] what are we talking about
but getting up on time
like you still need sleeping sometimes
yeah you you fly to you fly to the other
side of the [ __ ] country for six
seven hours okay you get in your [ __ ]
[ __ ] hotel at 1 30 a.m those dicks are
coming to pick you up at five they
didn't even call ahead and be
considerate of go what kind of coffee do
you need can i bring you some breakfast
why do all that i do all that on my all
his own i do that on my own my own so at
7 30 when they get there i'm prepared
when i get back to that hotel room and i
get high i'll sleep like a baby right
but after two shows the weed there's too
much energy there's too much energy oh
after the show i know for a fact that
i'm not going to sleep step four
i know for a fact even this week i'm in
portland my flight i got to be at the
airport at 5 30. i get back to burbank
at 8 00 am yeah i'm out
so 5 30 if i gotta be at the airport at
5 30 that means i'm lurking at 4 30 in
the morning so i'm prepared for that
three hours sleep after the comedy club
so what i do is
saturday mornings
i get up eat breakfast i walk around i
get high do whatever the [ __ ] i do i get
back to that room about 10 o'clock jack
and ralphie does the same because
ralphie will call me on saturdays from
the road and i go what time is it that
that free time that little time that's
it
yeah once i take that nap after that
it's over because i'm sleeping straight
till three yeah because we're at work i
have to and i don't [ __ ] work you
know me i don't sleep lately ever on
saturdays i don't do lunches i don't do
nothing because i know i'm gonna be
lurking all night
i know that i have a chance of falling
asleep for three hours but probably
probably not even yeah i'm used to it
now bro they got a flight i'm taking i'm
going to jersey and i'm still flying
into kennedy jack i'm going to new
brunswick because there's no kind of
everything is connecting to jersey now
there's only one direct and that's
virgin but virgin gets me in at eight a
virgin will get me in thursday cool at 2
30 sunday i ain't wait until one to fly
back to hell no it gets me back here at
3 30. i can't do it i can't do it hey
man so virginia look at southwest
they've got one right get two chairs
it's too connecting no no no no no
listen southwest is good for two hours
yeah after two hours your back starts to
hurt yeah no there's no entertainment
there's nothing there's no
uh there's no that's what gives you free
tv
they give you a free tv on the wi-fi you
gotta bring your own tv and i gotta lock
in and all that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i sit
next to
this
oh my god listen i know american
airlines i got 200 000 miles on that
yeah right platinum virgin on platinum
right listen there's no southwest it's
from
california
nevada california lax to austin yeah
houston two hours two to 210 215.
anything after two and a half hours of
southwest you're asking for trouble this
whole story started with the pimple in
the ass because of the bust if you want
a pimple in the ass that's that bad
fly [ __ ] southwest so what happened
was i come back on a monday night for
[ __ ] el paso i've been sitting on the
bus for 12 hours i must have fell asleep
sideways i was about 370 at the time and
the crease of the fat in my ass
built the pimple up
three or four inches from my [ __ ]
headed like uh
northerly north
north my [ __ ] is right here on the
cheek on the inside
i got a pimple that stuck out an inch
and it was developing like it started
with an itch how did he find it so
quickly how did i find it i couldn't sit
he couldn't every time i went to sit i'm
like wow something hurts and then he
pulled the hair out like 12 seconds i
took a [ __ ] mirror
and i took these are the days when i was
like in my apartment
and i had to look at my ass and bend
over
guys it was a white head on my ass oh my
god that was throbbing it hurt so much
oh and i couldn't take it on when i'm
sitting there talking to ralphie and i
remember that i go he was telling me a
story about something and i'm sitting
and i finally open up my pants from the
front
yeah i don't want to wear on
my pants no you didn't even you didn't
even take your pants off that's when you
were pants that's when you had the ball
the ball pants i stuck my hand through a
hole in the [ __ ] yoga position
i had to get to a yoga position lee and
i had to squeeze the pimple
but turn it
but i had to turn the skin down
so it would go pop
and lee you could hear it go pop and it
was just a yellow ball of pus i had to
go back in and i had with my fingernails
i had to take the [ __ ] i took a piece
of skin out you take stuff out of them
yeah yeah you have an ingrown hair from
sitting twisted on your butt
if you sit down all day you will have
pimples on your ass dramatically all
those fat people that walk around and
work in offices look at their ass from
time to time oh my god it's gotta be big
it's like strippers for some reason
strippers always got a big white head
if you look at the stripper's ass when
she's dancing close look up closely you
always see a little little white head on
their cheek
i'm just teasing it's just a joke will
you look at these people yeah lately
it's going in it's like really it's just
really experienced i didn't know you had
to pull stuff out of them well when it's
an ingrown hair like wrong hair like
that on your ass cheek yeah jesus and it
was a long hair too i saw it made me
look vomit a little bit in my mouth it's
totally gross terrible terrible i know
people think that comedy when you sell
those buses for that long
and now
now i you know it's it's
you fly so much oh yeah man
and
southwest i love them i'm not saying
that they're a bad airline not at all
southwest is thick fast burbank i take
southwest i'm from whatever that thing
is the level that you yeah yeah
a level i love southwest i used to hate
the way they board but they poured much
quicker dude so much quicker so much
better it works so much better get the
[ __ ] on [ __ ] you get on [ __ ] you get off
8 15 8 30. you get a seat in the air you
sit there you give people dirty looks as
they walk by
i had to do the math because i i forgot
to check in one time and i was like b 30
or something b 20 but i didn't mad
there's like 96 island uh window seats
so as long as you're in the first 96
you're cool
you did the math i got nervous dude
you are such that's the jewish thing
you've ever said to me and you're just
i'm a chubby guy i don't know i've never
had a million years dude dude you've got
you got the flag of israel right there
and that is the jewish thing you've ever
said that you've counted all the [ __ ]
windows
but not today really oh my god
dude here's what i do because because
i'm fat i gotta buy two seeds right and
i don't mind that's no big deal here's
how cool [ __ ] southwest is though if
that plane ain't full
they give me one of those
uh uh seats back for free for free and
so the next time so i fly you know when
i live in nashville the two hour flight
i'm in i'm in boston two hour flight i'm
in chicago two hour flight i'm in miami
you know 85 percent of my work is within
two hour flight so i go over there
southwest this is how good they are in
nashville holy [ __ ] i got there 10
minutes before the plane was supposed to
take off and they go ralphie we've
already got you checked in
the plane is now having mechanical
problems and as soon as you get on it'll
be fixed okay and they rush this was
before the tsa bypass all that [ __ ]
they were like just pat him down get him
on the plane and they wheeled me from in
on one of them go-karts because this is
how much southwest loves you they come
they got me to that plane as soon as i
stepped on hey the problem solved yeah
everybody clapped i had my two seats
right there waiting for me like a doctor
and and those guys love me they come out
they're the best burbank is cool south
west brother burbank
people that's orlando casillo's daughter
oh yeah she works dirt she's the front
desk managers right sometimes i get
there what are you whatever if i know
she's there you got clap yes one time
she took me into the southwest thing and
i was eating food sandwiches from the
[ __ ] lunch room they had a party i'm
in the party
because you got delayed so you might as
well come with me and i went into yeah
and they had little sandwiches cut up
with potato chips and people from
southwest were back there eating and she
put me right there she goes you know i
can get you they're really nice i didn't
say they were a bad no but amazing south
western today it's not that incredible
you know i mean it's again here's the
thing it's not that comfortable if the
plane is packed and we're a fat [ __ ]
right okay my shoulder goes on southwest
man me too oh my god i get shoulder pain
on southwest i know you know i made a
mistake i connected one time to save 300
or two papers you know because you're
always looking to save right fly and
flying is something that if you're
looking to save you're going to have an
uncomfortable journey
prepare for it go on their website
spirit
you know united has a thing where they
give you a bigger seat and they give you
security clearance yeah for 75 bucks
it's worth every time yeah because that
means i'm i'm walking in the first class
line right there's first class
class and then there's economy in the
economy united office that you have to
scroll all the way down it's 75 each way
it's worth it it's so [ __ ] worth it
you just buy it today's economy is worth
it goddamn couple weeks ago i was i was
i was uh i was upgraded to first class
and i still didn't almost make the
flight because of the security line yeah
this is what's going on out there people
said if you're flying over the holidays
i'm telling you right now if they
already don't get early
earlier thing or get it if you have a
passport by the way and you what in your
travel a lot just go get tsa
pre-approved it takes about five minutes
okay which utterly scared the living
[ __ ] out of me that i just show up with
my passport and my id
and they asked me like six questions
like do you love america of course uh
are you a lot allied with any of the uh
a terrorist group against them against
the country and i go not only do i
[ __ ] hate them [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking
dirty sons of [ __ ] okay they shot at
me [ __ ] you all right i hate russians
i'm bona fide jack [ __ ] that and they go
have a nice day mr may i had to raise my
hand sign a piece of paper boom had it
then and all you do is go up there you i
you don't have to take anything off no i
don't want you no shoes no [ __ ] email
me yeah they emailed me and i i showed
my wife aren't you that you
access to your social media or is that
no that's [ __ ] what are you talking
about i hear stuff i don't know that's
that's [ __ ] but you know what you
know what though it would be smart and
let me tell you every business i'm doing
it i put on the bus
a tower a mobile cell phone tower
a wi-fi rather that like the largest one
you can get on in a mobile unit and so
it gets free wi-fi at all my shows all
right but what happens to log in is i
get all your information so next time
i'm in the area i can hit you up and and
and go hey i'm here all right and that
it's that's how i do it i provide it
cost me a lot of money to do it but at
least i get something in exchange and
they get free internet you know what i
mean right that's cool it's it's really
cool and that's what you got to do for
people but businesses all around are
doing that but you know what they do
it's not like on uh southwest you give
them their email and if you got like an
ipad or something
you can watch real tv and they've got
movies on there too all right and you
can flip channels and it's real time and
that's for free instead of like uh what
is it boying or something like that and
that's like [ __ ] 22
god damn
and it's [ __ ] you can't work twitter's
or nothing but
that's garbage that that's way too
[ __ ] much i mean like a monster
southwest gives you free wi-fi yeah but
it's
what you want to why i don't get it here
so you just have to they don't they
don't want to pay for screens so you
could bring out your tablet and log and
just you just log in you just hit accept
and then they have like a whole bunch of
tv stations yeah but you can get all
your wi-fi everything on there and
everything especially if you're a-list
you get everything you get you get out
of it for instance
i do not fly jet blue i'm too wide in
the ass and it doesn't i don't live in a
hub of it but i do live in a hub
nashville is a hub for uh southwest and
you know they've got three directs i
took american here first class like a
doctor i was out of there at 6 15 on
saturday on halloween that was the first
one in there on there america's got a
nice flight today dude it's a fantastic
flight man they add one during the
winter yeah there's a problem like the
winter you have to look they add an
extra one on the way back because
usually you have to leave early and have
one at night yeah they get nervous about
dallas and and chicago so they add extra
direct to nashville because nashville's
such a great hub that
they you can get all to the south and
and right there from there like that's
like their emergency one like when
dallas has a ice storm and chicago's
[ __ ] up they they add extra flights to
other key cities just so like to miami
so they can bring people up to the east
coast it's crazy but that's what they do
they're smart you know they get they
they do it like they do baby they do it
like they do a lot of people don't fly
they get excited
i'm going to tell you what the best
ticket is in the business
what's that virgin
main cabin select
[ __ ] amen i tell you what virgin
first class is bomb dude i'm talking
about the main cabinet oh yeah the one
behind from
the ford first class oh my god it's
first class it's first class it's first
class first class like it's first class
first class for half the price
it's worth the price i have the price
the best seat in the business and
without a doubt you've got more leg
space actually than you are having first
class i've been more comfortable with
main cabinet select
than i am in first class you know yeah
because they have a desk i could put a
notebook down
i could actually [ __ ] type something
and you can i got gorilla hands bro you
can stretch them
it's got more space than first class
stuff you have to hit a button they
bring you free food yeah free booze
everything's on the house so it's still
first class only not in the first class
and you still stand on the first class
line that [ __ ] brit and if you want
to fly first class you call 12 hours
before the flight yeah if it ain't full
149 yeah boom they bump it
and then always go across the country
that's going across the only problem is
that like all right i want to go to
[ __ ] austin from lax right
now you got to go to san francisco first
oh yeah
that's the problem that i foresee
chicago i love to take virgin to chicago
but you know what
i don't want to get to lax at nine
yeah that's how i exit nine as well
that's a rough flight you know what get
american will get me anywhere at 5 00
a.m if i call them and ask
that's one thing about america that's
true that's one thing about american
airlines that they have flights that is
why i [ __ ] fly america they already
because
they got a vampire flight they got a 20
they got they got a 5 a.m to chicago
that means you have to be at lax at 4 00
a.m what type of human being are you
that you're lurking at 4 00 am without
drugs you yeah me
you know it would be more effective like
if they ran like southwest is almost a
24-hour a day airline um and especially
with it's all it's international flights
now but uh i'm telling you man american
is the smartest in the business they
lower the rates of what they could but
they run them all the [ __ ] time and
it it they lower the rates in that so
they have more people go to the off
times who are bargain hunting like the
rest of us used to and then main
consumers can pay at an accelerated rate
for the last immediate good flights that
aren't as full because the cheap people
got diverted to the other flights it's a
goddamn beautiful business model that's
how you [ __ ] make money
but it's amazing how much these
companies treat the customers like crap
like especially
when there's no there's no [ __ ]
reason why the i mean all right if you
are if you were the worst person in the
[ __ ] world
go work at the airport because no one
will [ __ ] about you because they don't
have time to fill out a form they don't
have time to [ __ ] can i talk to your
manager they just don't they got a plane
to catch so they go oh that guy was a
dick and they watch your next plane you
get it fits free it's awesome if you're
an [ __ ] go work it there about a year
ago i made a really bad mistake and this
is the type of person i am because i
know it's a corporation
i know it's a company and i know uh
i was you were gonna never have to know
i was having a chat today with somebody
about agents
and i said listen i know people who are
[ __ ] agents
but the agents are killer
yeah it doesn't matter
just because he's you know i was looking
at her uh here's the funniest thing ever
on imdb
they've got a rating for agencies and
managements and all that [ __ ] caa is
obviously number one
william morris is number two innovative
is like eight and then the ancient time
wins like 200 it's like 300.
you know
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
there's some management companies i
looked at
and here's what's [ __ ] up
you look at jeff's husband's management
yeah they're 4
300. a regular person will look at that
and go i wouldn't even talk to that
management company yeah
what do you mean four thousand dollars
cost that's how like that's the rating
that was the rating that was as far down
the list but they've got three clients
millionaires so it doesn't matter it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it doesn't matter
you understand me so it's all [ __ ]
what are the rankings based on
i guess the client's earnings
and uh that and yeah the client's
earnings and so like uh i'm with william
morris and they're i think worldwide
they're number one but here in america's
caa is especially in la all right but
william morris is bad ass who gives a
fat baby's dick that they're at that
level they're they're i mean unless
they're worthless or [ __ ] strung out
on something i mean there's been a lot
that have risen and fallen because of
what they're snorting and what they're
drinking on their [ __ ] expense but
man if you've got if you got one client
and you're that guy's manager and that
[ __ ] guy
is
a
kevin hart
your your rating would be i mean that
you only have one client and you're so
far down
but kevin will work hard and make a ton
of money but what if he takes two years
off
you know just to relax and build up a
new act you know that's why that's when
your rating drops to 5 000 like
sustenance i mean but how much tv does
even joe and and and kevin do anymore no
more no more they i mean is joe doing
he's still throwing people around at the
ufc's right right right but that's
that's that's true doesn't even have a
theatrical
some guy called me and they said he
would be
such a [ __ ] amazing action hero
and i understand i understand
god he would be free
amazing
okay with joe rogan okay with a [ __ ]
skull and tats and crazy [ __ ] okay
driving a hot rod to the [ __ ] desert
for hot [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm all
for that that [ __ ] nice ass corvette
of his [ __ ]
if you put a show on tv wouldn't you
want him to be executive produce i go he
probably would do it if i asked him but
it's the last thing on his mind
it's the la and if you understood his
life
he does the easiest path of resistance
you know we were talking about work
ethic a couple weeks ago you know he got
that job at the ufc as a volunteer
he called the guy and said i'll fly
myself out i just want to do something
with my time
do you guys have an idea what the ufc
pays him what he's become on that
channel he's like the voice of that [ __ ]
yeah this didn't come to him because he
trained he went to the right itt
institute of of uh [ __ ] yeah
balls he stepped up
and that's what this uh this whole
thing's about
[ __ ] balls so if you have this job
right guys this is how he looks at it
and i look at it the same way
right you got this job that flies you
into vegas or whatever every once a
month to call a fight they pay you a
shitload of money he gets residuals from
two shows guys yeah remember he was on
two cinder shows
hits
why would you want to drive
warner brothers and put up with that
yeah why you know how hard it is to be
the rock
it's it's [ __ ] you know how hard it
be the rock how is that see people in
the land then because he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing he's gonna wake
up one day and go first of all how many
needles can i stick in my blood
how many needles can i stick in my neck
before my kidney blows up because that's
how the public needs to see you all the
time he went on some show a month ago
and said he eats 20 pounds of fish a day
that's all great and dandy okay but you
got to stick me up with your body to be
that [ __ ] big hey me and you going to
some sushi spots we we got him on that
one yeah we got him
so i i don't know how hard it is you
have to train right now joe rogan has a
family
he's he's literally gonna come down the
hill why would you want he is a genius
what do i want what do i want do i want
the joey dear show not 20 million years
i'm 52.
i did blow for 30 [ __ ] years i i you
know i'm surprised i didn't foam in the
mouth with so much bad [ __ ] i ate like
the kardashian black guy oh yeah his
name is lamar
let me tell you i would foam at the
mouth those [ __ ] are the [ __ ] kiss
of death for 20 years i'm overwhelmed
you got to look at you got to look at
your [ __ ] weight you got to look at
your life and go how long am i going to
[ __ ] last so do i really want to
drive to paranormal every day and put up
with this faux pas producer and director
on their creative thoughts yeah for a
show for five more [ __ ] years and in
my glory to stick away from my kids the
kids are fine he's fine the ufc pays him
great money he goes on the road
when he wants to with the ufc so it's
all in house so yeah people make me
laugh when i go to these clubs they're
like so what's it gonna take for joe
rogan to come to my club i i want to say
listen ag to god
he comes in for one [ __ ] night
you know
in 98 being at the laugh factory one
night and i tell the story constantly as
whether people like him or dislike him
or he's not funny or funny
dane cook one night walked out of the
lab factory 99
and he came over and said hello to me
and i looked i'm going how was the last
stop last week he goes that's a [ __ ]
great club man yeah that was 96. but no
no i mean uh 2008 2001. he goes it's
2000. the only problem is
was a lot of work
yeah
wednesday through sunday
and i looked at him
and i didn't think about what he was
saying but i got it
dude and that guy had a ton of money and
we had two dollars to our name and we
would have we would have been
we would have loved it but no
he just he goes i just want to play
bigger places that's it it's just one
show that's it one show he put that out
there he made he put a plan he changed
he changed comedy with that movie with
that move and i saw it happening i
remember saying who started it dane is
the one who started it you know
everybody before from mitch hedberg
everybody wednesday through sunday maybe
stay until tuesday if the drugs are good
every [ __ ] body everybody dougie
stanhope uh everybody did it
[ __ ] dane cook was the first one that
broke the [ __ ] model the clubs had
had the control the whole time because
there wasn't in the after comedy died
after the 80s and the 90s were [ __ ]
dead there were no headliners that were
selling tickets okay so when comedy
started to come back up the clubs there
was less clubs and so these comics so
they could [ __ ] keep the money down
but now the dumb [ __ ] they got gritty
like they always do when they [ __ ]
start making money they start putting
all these comedy clubs everywhere and
then they go oh i got no [ __ ]
headliners and then that's when we got
the power and it was [ __ ] dang cook
that showed the way you can say go [ __ ]
your wednesday and eat a dick on sunday
i'm doing no you know what i'm i'll come
in thursday for friday morning radio and
that's it
that's it and i'm back at home in l.a uh
early
what's up
what do you think you're dealing with
lisa
[ __ ]
jesus christ huh
these chocolates are good [ __ ] yeah
they're good
you want me to say why the only reason i
went to church was the other day why
because it was the 36th
anniversary of the night
that morning was the
that morning
was the 36th anniversary of the day i
got home
steven villas called the show my friend
saba villa
a couple times that he had a party one
night
he had had a party
in august that year and they put he had
older brothers this kid stephenville you
never met a uh ralphie no great kid he's
got a cover band called the past masters
and his he they had a shed and when we
were growing up
his brothers were part of this crew and
they [ __ ] had parties not big drug
parties they weren't drug parties they
were about music
and they they did crazy things like they
would eat glass
you know like
eat a mouse's head off
so one day this is way before us this is
oh yeah
my friend
so summer's 79 i went over there one day
for a party and the only young kids that
were invited to the party were me a
villa and this kid conti and at this
party they took a garb they took a
garbage can
and they filled it up with everything
they had they put hawaiian punch in it
and they took bees
remember he called and told the story
that the brothers took bees i tried to
think about dr eating the bees in the
[ __ ] thing
so and with ice and this stuff had like
one fifty one rub that tastes like god
it tasted terrible they're so [ __ ]
they to scoop it out you had to do this
it was in a garbage can and they had
chunks of fruit in it and i'm back there
smoking pot the next thing you know i'm
getting woken up in uh sulu's front yard
anthony cesulo he's in dallas texas and
i'm getting woken up by ray ernesto ray
honestly was a cop from the neighborhood
that would come down and play basketball
on sundays but he always wore colored
socks and drove me crazy
and at the end of the fight at the end
of the basketball game that was the
argument ray you got to go home with
your color sucks how about i punch you
in my phone you right you're going to
punch me tomorrow you're [ __ ] 40. i'm
[ __ ] 10 what go [ __ ] yourself right
but ray was a cool [ __ ] ray
picked me up and he was cooking what
happened i don't know i blacked out i
got [ __ ] up because come on i'll drive
me home and he knocked on the door my
mom answered and she's like what's going
on i go ma i got [ __ ] up i fell asleep
on since thing she goes go [ __ ]
sleeping off you idiot she yelled at me
this was like the end of august this is
the first day that's when parents were
[ __ ] parents and police for goddamn
police
please didn't have to be
[ __ ] parents too man in the
neighborhood right i'll never forget
that i was [ __ ] hungover
this was the first time ever that i was
hung over so i got in like at 5 30. it
was starting to the light was starting
to come out
5 30 a sophomore and i i'm going to be a
sophomore this is like two weeks before
they put me in the hospital for a lung
infection i'm [ __ ] up i'm not doing
drugs though guys i didn't do drugs i
was smoking pot then i was high i was i
never i was not i wasn't a big drinker
but i drank a little up much and i'll
never forget that
my mom could drink early dog and it was
a sunday morning so i got home like at
five i passed on
about 10 o'clock in the morning
i could hear like ice cubes and [ __ ]
that's what i woke up to i could hear
cuban music
and
i heard her come up the stairs and she
go oh yeah
that means wake up i made breakfast or
lunch
and she had like a class in those days
towards the end
she used to drink a bloody mary with a
heineken and [ __ ] right what the [ __ ]
makes a bloody mary with a heineken
walking around your house she was such a
speck
like she was such a straight she
wouldn't even cut the celery she'd just
[ __ ] break it and put it in a drink
and eat it while she was talking to me
you know but you have to appreciate this
this and you can't write this you can't
write this you know you're supposed to
cut the lettuce off the celery yeah she
was such a smick she just ate it right
she just ate it [ __ ] it she was
different she loved tomato juice that v8
oh [ __ ] that's what she lived i still
love that dude i drink that like twice a
week three times she wouldn't put
tabasco in her bloody mary she put
frank's red sauce oh not mean so anyway
she looks at me
i'm [ __ ] i got a headache that's
pounding
and she goes oh yeah they're going to
have you i cook for you and then she
goes she looked at me for like five
minutes
she took a piece in her celery and she
goes
now you know what i feel like in the
morning and she [ __ ] walked out
though i've never
and that was like a prolific thing in my
world like i never thought about it
again okay so it's august a [ __ ] you
get the best it's august a [ __ ]
whatever
but she said it very pate patois
like now you know what i feel like at
the moment okay
this is how you want to live your life
and she just walked out of the room
okay don't call me that's for real no
this is the end of august now it's
september october
november i love you i get invited to a
halloween party it's a saturday night
[ __ ] crazy was your finger making
chicks yet
three days before this [ __ ] party a
girl pulls me aside that's beautiful she
goes hey
what do you think of this girl
i go why do you ask she goes she wants
to get together with you
you want her numb and i go sure but she
had just broken up with a kid and even
that in 1979
i went up to the kid like a man
and the kid was a tough kid and i went
up to him and i said can i talk to you
for saying you already know
i go uh
i know you're not with her anymore do
you mind and he goes you know what i
like you but i do mind i'm still in love
with it
just give it to me okay [ __ ] you
i just you know but that's how deep i
was in 79 guys at 15 i already knew
there's boundaries and got to be a man
you got to be respectful and that
halloween night we all dressed up like
ghosts and we took a hit ass and we went
to the gamiel's garage
and it was tremendous it was tremendous
at 11 o'clock
i went to [ __ ] meet her and some girl
came and said she's not coming you have
to go get her
and i was like what and i the girl was
hot and on the way walk in fact timmy
holloway is her cousin he's listening to
this podcast
robin thompson it was me and her robin
thompson started walking her boyfriend
glenn zamaneke was a man
already me me and robin were 15.
her boyfriend was a man that's how hot
this [ __ ] was he was a [ __ ] man his
[ __ ] didn't even date high school kids
he got out of the car and thought we
were leaving together and started
yelling at her but i stuck up for him
you know he was like you know i'll deal
with you some other time and he
you know was very nice to me that night
and all this [ __ ] went down i forgotten
the whole thing i forgot to call home
that was the rule of the house you gotta
[ __ ] call home
so saturday night was this night it was
a halloween party
but it was the it was in those days
that year if you look at 1979 map
halloween was on a weekend me and ghetto
boys and treat no halloween
it was like on a wednesday so but the
party was saturday yeah so it really it
was like maybe or halloween was like
monday and this party was on a saturday
that was it was like october 28th you
like trick or treat like three times so
what happened was i stayed there and
austin i realized it's three in the
morning
and i call home and my mom and she goes
what the [ __ ]
and i listen i'm up here but there's no
buses it was a wednesday it was one uh
trick but that sort of but what was the
date on the [ __ ] saturday nightly
the
third
no the saturday before that 27th the
27th because she died on the eighth lee
so she died that wednesday after that
not after the halloween 10 days after
halloween so it was a week and a half
she died a week and a half later so she
gave me the speech on a sunday night and
she died november 8th so look at it
you follow me you see how the cop wow so
that sunday she goes i'm on the couch
what are you going to do and i go i
don't know she goes we'll take a taxi
home i go i'm not going to take a taxi
home i got other buddies with me we're
going to walk home together
and i'd done the acid and stuff and the
asset was coming down i was getting like
the little jingles and [ __ ] so something
happened somebody took a ride downtown
but by this time we were talking it's
5am i'm not going to call her back she
was already sleeping
and i'll never forget that i [ __ ]
like my friends dropped me off i had a
ghost costume on
and i walked up the [ __ ] stairs and
as i was putting the [ __ ] key in the
door dog
she opened it
grabbed me with one [ __ ] hand and
just smacked me across the face she
hadn't smacked me in four years five
years before that she i was a big boy
you know and she that just wasn't
that just wasn't her ammo you know to
hit me she would say i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you two years before that she did
light me on fire with a bounty roll she
pulled me out of carmine balzano's
backyard
so but she was passed she was passed
and she slammed the door she goes let me
tell you something
she goes someday you're going to be
[ __ ] married and you're going to have
a [ __ ] wife and you better [ __ ]
call her every hour on the hour that's
the deal in this house you could stay
out all [ __ ] night i don't give a
[ __ ] what you do drinking with your
stupid buddy she went off
but she does all i want and i'm standing
there going you just smacked me in the
[ __ ] face hard
like it was a hard smack to the face
like it was still stinging
and she's like you know
you [ __ ] idiot you know what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you staying out there
seven morning get upstairs to your room
i don't even want to look at you and i'm
hours past
i'm like i might even move out like
that's it i might even move the [ __ ] out
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] this place [ __ ] this
place [ __ ] you no wonder your husband
left you and the other one died
[ __ ] you
holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] real as it
gets that's real
my father died at 37. and then one who
was a killer left up because he hit him
in the head with a [ __ ] saint
a [ __ ] catholic saint that's what go
ahead lupe no no santa barbara the hat
the man that with the sword did he flick
the cigarette and she [ __ ] waited for
him to fall asleep and she broke it over
his head
nobody could deal with that he didn't
even know what to do he was lost he was
in a deep sleep
so that night i went to bed thinking you
know after she got home from closing the
bar
yeah they came home together and they
were talking and they were sitting like
this he was sitting on a chair and
something happened when she wanted a
cigarette
and he took it and instead of handing it
to her
we were all school cubans right you
don't throw nothing in that house no
that's really doing it that's [ __ ]
rude
i don't give a [ __ ]
if somebody flicked this egg if i can't
i have a cigarette like you're saying it
wasn't even thirsty it wasn't
can i have a superior wife sure you
[ __ ] threw it in me it's the same
[ __ ] thing it's rude it wasn't even
[ __ ] rude but my my mom's demented
drunk head it was a disrespect thing so
she waited for him to go to bed she hit
him in the head
and he [ __ ] left the next day but so
i'm walking up the stairs thinking
that's just
i'm walking
up the stairs oh yeah oh yeah i'm
walking up the stairs thinking you know
what i ain't stop i ain't tolerating
this [ __ ] no more
you know i'm 15 and a half
i get a job i can live with the balzanos
that was my plan
i don't need this [ __ ] people hit me i
remember one of the balzanos when i was
working at hashbrooke heights one time
yeah pete yeah
so
the next morning she woke me up again
and she's like yeah i cook something and
she goes but let me tell you something
she just get up like she got up she like
i was like oh [ __ ]
and she goes first off i'm sorry for
putting my hand on you you're too old
for me to be hitting you
but number two she goes i just want you
to understand something
all i want out of this deal is for you
to grow up and be a man
that's it
i don't give a [ __ ] how you do it i want
you to grow up to be a man okay
when you tell somebody you're gonna call
them
you call
and she kissed me in the cheek and she
walked out and i didn't think much of it
i didn't think much of it i just sat
there
and i was like you know what whatever a
man what the [ __ ] is a guy i am a
[ __ ] man i was just sucking titties
behind the high school lesson i'm a man
i'm a [ __ ] man i worked last summer i
made 75 hours a day you know my head
and the morning you know whatever so 10
days later
when i found her dead on the floor
the first thought was like she's never
gonna find that i got left back but the
second thought was this is what she was
saying she gave me a she gave me a heads
up that's all she wanted out of this for
me to be a man whatever i knew in her
world what that meant
but i just wanted to celebrate that i
know that she liked churches yeah my mom
loved going to [ __ ] pretty there was
a church down the block from saint
patrick's cathedral there's in the 70s
and 60s and every year on february 26th
my mom would give the guy a hundred
and bring him a bottle of chivas and
whatever flowers and they would set the
casket up like a faith casket and my mom
would do a [ __ ] thing for my dad and
she used to say i love [ __ ] we used to
go to churches just to [ __ ] uh look
at churches
even though she demented she would go to
churches then in the eighth and the
sixth in the fifth grade
i was ten that's 1973. and that year
something happened the new york mets
went to the playoffs the nlcs playoffs
against look it up lisa against
assistant
what am i looking for
look up
the new york mexicans the cisco that he
reads 1973 poor meds this is how the
royals whip the [ __ ] out of them
they beat up the 17 specs and they did
it right there and [ __ ] i mean
[ __ ]
who's that who's that black guy
sparkly
he took his hat back off okay jerry
seinfeld was boohoo and back to his
billion dollars okay
from nowhere [ __ ] no money royals i'm
so proud of them god bless it's an
american dream it really is it's a
[ __ ] american dream good for them
whipped them whipped them to death at
their house what year was it 73 1973 a
new york met from the cincinnati reds
tremendous october 6th to 10th
and new york won the series three game
to two
but they lost the a's right pete rose
beat the [ __ ] out of bud harris in the
second base it was tremendous
when he was when he was uh that year
sliding in but that year my mom
when i made my first community you were
talking about oh yeah
so what lee what what lee uh did you so
you went to jewish instruction when you
were growing up you saw the kind what
days it's saturdays no um
it was wednesdays a lot wednesdays and
sundays sometimes hey did you have the
little
no nice oh thank god
that would have been my best that would
have been this is what i'm from now
experience you should eat some pot
cookies and say [ __ ] just [ __ ] with
people's head
lee if you did that you know no idea how
to grow those yes you do
how do you grow those you just love it
yeah just let it [ __ ] what let's just
do pre
who gives a [ __ ] you know i'm looking at
an [ __ ]
you get some money on the sponsor oh
yeah well these jew whacks
and get you one of them mustaches too it
makes you yeah it makes you look like
one of them [ __ ] evil villains like
you got a [ __ ] tied up on a drink track
that's what you need lee
that would be the look
yeah
come on lee you got to do that come on
you got that stash there's no way that's
my mother dude that's your look that's
your look i and then shave your head and
you'll be a circus strong man okay
that's what you'll be doing you'll be
sorry
you'll be fine
i'm sorry it's just cracking me up my
[ __ ] mom that hash was fantastic i
used to i used to go to this [ __ ]
sacred heart school for boys
and how they did
what they did was
you had a lineup eighth grade seventh
grade sixth grade so to go to church
there was this belt and you had to ring
the bell so sister anna would go all
right eighth grade and she'd ring the
bell and you're going well my mom used
to eyeball that belt
because it was made from copper and it
had a wooden head
and the cuban big saint in cuba
which is october 6 i got another quote
she's you're supposed to have a copper
belt
and if you want money you have to ring
that bell
so my mom went there on the way home
she's like just just get close to me my
mom shoplifted the [ __ ] balcony
and she would take it to the met games
and ring that [ __ ] belt so in the
back of her mind that bell was
everything that bell was what was
bringing her luck every time i'd see her
she'd give me a kiss and go you're a
genius that church is bringing me good
luck with the [ __ ] belt the mets keep
winning the which you stole from the
church just bringing me the lord that's
amazing so every time the match would
play at home she'd bring the bell and if
she went to a mech game she'd take the
bell and put in her purse and she ring
the bell at the mech game this is true
[ __ ] story this is how crazy this is
what i came from oh man i know you don't
have all this time but have you thought
about like trying to go back to 1973 med
game like video and see if you can hear
the bell
that's crazy [ __ ] you're blowing my
[ __ ] mouth on my [ __ ] i would i
couldn't i couldn't no no no no i
couldn't i couldn't do it you would hear
it too you would hear her going rusty's
tab
she would throw chicken wings when he'd
run back she hated rusty
where do you want to sit
you know do you want to sit in right
field and i think rusty where did rusty
stop play 73
mets was it 73
whoever rusty stuff they had a horrible
i think it was rusty staub and george
theodore
the [ __ ] oh my mom used to get
so pissed
he was a right fielder yeah he always
had to hit the cutoff that
so he would have to run past her
he would have to run past her
if she would sit there and he ran past
it she would lose her mind she would go
ballistic all eight times he run oh yeah
ruth
she [ __ ] yelled him in spanish and
then if she was close enough she'd throw
chicken wings on him oh yeah
so when the guy would ask her where do
you want to sit and say he'd say like
what do you want to say my mom would go
i don't like that [ __ ] dude
so she would sit on the other side who
is the left fielder
let's see oh god oh god
oh my god you're giving me a break
oh god
buster had wayne garrett on third so she
was in love with wayne gary wayne
garrett took his dick out my mom would
jump the fence and suck his dick and tom
sieve at the same time
okay your mom's got heart give me the
team
by the way uh this friday i'll be at the
club nokia here in los angeles if you're
a church member please come in i'd love
you i'd love to see you live i get to do
i'm going to do about two hours and blow
your [ __ ] minds
come on baby what's the team who's the
left fielder then and who was the
[ __ ] third baseman all right you
wanted the left fielder was cleon jones
cleon jones who was the third baseman
yeah bad [ __ ] dog he reminds me
of david wright the hot corner they used
to call it and my mother loved wayne
garrett so she could tolerate clan
and my mother used to call cleon jones
because he was black so my mom would
clap and wayne garrett she liked wayne
guy right but if you put her on the
other side
she'd be tormented the whole game was
rusty stuff she turned and look at me at
that people i don't wanna look at this
[ __ ] i gotta sit there and look
at this [ __ ] so
why wouldn't you like him
he did an error she lost like ten
thousand dollars one time because he
dropped the ball and that was it that's
it my mother's world or was it because i
no he did something stupid he couldn't
hit he couldn't throw it to first base
he had to hit the cut off i don't know
what he did to my mother my mom just
didn't like him so my mom if she's on
the right side not only would she ring
the bell for the match but then she put
voodoo on rest he stopped with the same
bag
right so that year
bro listen to me
the [ __ ] mets beat the reds right
uh
are you sure i'm not like [ __ ] like
jesus christ yeah they won three three
that's one of the three do you
understand what
that was
for the [ __ ] mets to beat the reds
the reds were beginning a dynasty that
was the big redness that was the big red
machine now you know what happened [ __ ]
you know what happened
my mother when they went to the world
series my mother put i remember i was
still going to sacred heart school for
boys
i still remember that playing this day
because my mom had that belt
and if listen
this is even going to get creepy here
it's even gonna get creepier not only do
you
the school you go in on sundays
and then you come home on thursdays
here's where it really gets creepy lee
go even deeper see what day the world
series was on the game that that that
what was the series when the oakland a's
beat the the mets 1973 world series 1972
world series look at the day they
clinched so this is really going to
knock you [ __ ] out okay oh my
gosh see if it was a sunday
the day they won that game the oakland
a's beat the mets game six was on a
sunday was it six games
seven games okay uh sunday october 20th
who the [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
with gentlemen yeah yeah so listen to me
listen to me i don't know listen to me
i still remember
i don't remember right i still remember
what's his name catching the ball and my
mother looking over at me and going
let's go we're going back to that
[ __ ] school
and on the way her like playing she
wouldn't even look at that [ __ ] belt
so for the last three months
all she does is she loves this bell she
put the bell down at night and let it
campbell next to it
she cut her chicken heads and fed them
she did the whole thing singer yeah that
[ __ ] she gives a blessing the day the
mess lost she personally got in the car
because usually she'd go to the bar
and my stepdad or one of my mom's
friends would drive me and we'd all go
out to dinner as a family and then my
mom would go to the bar because you have
to be there till five
no three if you were working the bingo
on sunday
um
yeah man that catholic church
my mom personally drove me to the
[ __ ] school
got me out i could see she was agitated
the whole time
in the middle of the agitation she gave
me a hug
and she goes do me a favor
get this [ __ ] kiss about kiss a death
belt away from me right like why are you
touching that [ __ ] thing they've been
looking for that belt for three months
they've been doing searches with dogs
for that [ __ ] belt
oh my god and i go you put the [ __ ]
belt back you robbed it here we are in
front of the church the nuns are 10 feet
10.
i'm [ __ ] 10 and my mom's telling me
go put this but i don't ever want to see
that [ __ ] bell again i don't want to
see that i don't want to see that bell
and i don't want to see rusty stop as
long as i live i swear to god i don't
know what i hit my mom used to get
superstitious against certain things
okay so now the bell had carried her
throughout the whole baseball not only
that the bell helped
the mets beat the cincinnati reds which
at that time were royalty yeah
okay
now because they lost in game six or in
game seven the bell was bad luck she
didn't want in the [ __ ] house take
this [ __ ] bell out of here like i
said she personally helped how would you
think she lost on that bet
because you know she bet the [ __ ] out of
the 50 000.
jesus
i'd hate that [ __ ] too my mother
i burned that bell my mother had a uh a
gambling problem what women do they
think with those slot machines
my mom made you look like a [ __ ] my
mom was a betting baby all sports no
just baseball baseball and horses
and that the horses will kill you it's
every day you can't do anything every
day in life
she lost everything because of her
baseball bat
everything and her teams for betting
baseball with the red sox
at that time and they were hot then
those are the ones that were great so
this whole last week
was really you know i watched the
[ __ ] mech games i watched them did i
cheer for them i got to tell you
something
i was cheering for them up to when they
went to shea stadium the first night and
when i saw them singing ring me a song
you're a shadow man whatever that billy
joel thing
that was it for me i was disgusted i
have never been that this that's not the
new york i left
they were hugging each other and they
were singing sing me a song you're a
piano man and billy joel was in the top
acting like a jerk
that stuff drives me crazy dawg that's a
baseball field you're supposed to go and
throw things and ring bells
and yell up sandles and [ __ ] they've
created into something else that's what
pissed me off about though that's why i
got so mad i might say you sang for two
nights also when they're getting beat up
in shade no that's why i kept tweeting
last night didn't you see what i was
tweeting last night where's [ __ ]
billy joe get him sing it that's the
night they won the night that he [ __ ]
sang that song
now they're losing where's billy [ __ ]
joe when you need him
where the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] sucker uncle
[ __ ] yourself billy joe
that's what
kansas city let me tell you what's on
what kansas city played kansas city
played what my man brad pitt was trying
to sell money ball money ball is and you
know why did you did you watch the
series [ __ ] yeah didn't watch it and i
was disgusted with him because are you
serious because i like that piece of
[ __ ] monday night game
did you watch that [ __ ] football game
that was hot garbage i was what would
you watch it i was here he was here let
me tell you what the [ __ ] you guys you
know this one got a [ __ ]
wasn't he was shooting somebody in those
[ __ ] israelis in belarus right now
and they're both cussing out dirty
[ __ ] russians he knows he can't i
know
he was googling his [ __ ] cousins all
right
listen yeah did you notice what kansas
city did
and i love that
i hate when people forget about
the game small ball small ball lee they
stole bases they stole i love when
people steal they put pressure you
really want to [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
and if you look at the cincinnati reds
the big red machine
that's all they did their job and next
time classic baseball the cincinnati
reds play you sit there and you watch
that whole game and you're gonna go oh
my god
nobody had more than 15 home runs eric
foster small boss small ball the main
job they did
was singles get a single and stealing
singles is something that's forgotten
about this yeah man you know do you know
that's why ricky ricky henderson played
baseball so long and for so many teams
because think about it he played for the
red sox he played for everybody ricky
henny played for everybody listen
ricky is was goofball dumb but he was
one of the greatest baseball players to
ever get behind all right this guy if
you've got a pitcher and he is out out
of business at 96 pitches and ricky gets
on base with a bun or a [ __ ] single
or a walk sometimes he gets on there he
jumps out that guy's gonna have to throw
over there three or four times he's
gonna wear out his arm they're gonna
have to bring that middle reliever
that's a piece of [ __ ] that hadn't
worked in eight days and and then the
[ __ ] they have to go through three
closers so what do they do the next day
ricky henderson blows out their next guy
that's what genius small ball is and
that's what they did man they played
[ __ ] great baseball man they played
great baseball
beautiful college
cincinnati red games the lead off was
always joe morgan and he always stole
and once he stole once geronimo came on
those [ __ ] indians those geronimos
they go crazy and they had like three
people who would steal on you pete rose
would steal in your ass you know and
pete rose wasn't a thief but he just
you know it just gorilla you and if you
watched there was a
game maybe eight years ago
that they actually showed the [ __ ]
picture
just going like i don't want to deal
with this ever again this was not
baseball this was torture
because it's small ball it's slow torch
every pitch something happens there's
always something happening every time
you let that ball go it's either a
single a bunt or this motherfucker's
stealing that's torture on a picture he
can't you got a duck you lose your
concentration it's [ __ ] crazy and
then and that's well i used to love
baseball i used to know i know
everything about the red sox there's 162
games
before the postseason i don't have time
to watch all those games it's like i
don't know well not every one of them
but watch one of each series and feel
like a fan
you know
you know what i mean i like the houston
astros i i started stand up there in 90.
i i loved them
me and john wesling
we went for a foul ball and a kid little
kid was going for a foul ball we were
stoned out of our balls and instead of
me squashing that kid for that [ __ ]
foul ball i broke the seat okay
and the kids got the ball and
everybody's cheering and we're on the
big screen and i'm holding that chair
together [ __ ] i got that just
got my left hand on the chair up again
john's laughing he goes you broke that
jab
this [ __ ] chair is done i broke
that asymptom and been there 30
years up we got up it fell to four
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
pieces
you guys swear to god get johnny wesson
on the phone that is so [ __ ] funny oh
my god you broke a couple of things
[ __ ] i've broken a lot of [ __ ] i
broke it a lot of times i just could
break lawn chairs launches
remember the pittsburgh funny bone yeah
the home of creepo that used to have
naked women pictures all around the bar
yeah right i hated that i hear always
you say hey
dad i hate lawn chairs though yeah
there's the chair you have on your
balcony i i never knew why you had that
goddamn chair i broke one and you broke
one well i broke i was like pushing the
jaw and you came and just talked
tormented well from a fat guy this is
the worst chance
when you shot your pilot for vh1 didn't
i break a chair yes yes something
happened yeah
it was awesome
for a long
time oh my god it was so [ __ ] funny
bro one time with sleep apnea a chair
broke in miami dude dude you broke
gavin's toilet
remember you went in there and you just
sat down too
and you broke that [ __ ] toilet and
and then you made the slow creep
and water came out and played together
and gavin got out of his because you
were sleeping in my
and that you're like [ __ ] him i'm going
in here i broke gavin's [ __ ] futon
that was classic dog i heard that thing
snapping eight ways
when you're a fat [ __ ] you break [ __ ]
sometimes
without even knowing it's the most
embarrassing thing
living like a fat [ __ ] and you break a
ton of [ __ ]
as [ __ ] clothes i have ripped clothes
i remember one time
i'm in one time in somebody's car in a
jeep they had i went to get the handle
and i went to pull up and half the
[ __ ] roof came down
oh man stop being a fat [ __ ] man
ain't nothing easy let me do some shout
outs and get the [ __ ] out of here i like
to thank mac
mike and mary johnson at unique bows
thank you very much for the bows we put
them on a little hair for halloween
thank you for listening rusty
shackleford dead squad dallas and the
rest of you crazy
guys man sandman
benito munoz sean cappuccino jimmy
carroll and gert brooks you know i know
he's watching is my man d in colorado
who's a cool [ __ ] yeah i know in
colorado that [ __ ] has got weed
15 foot tall
15.
the biggest ass butt
dude he's a great guy man that guy's cut
from rare i just talked to him on
twitter a couple days ago he's a good
yeah he's a good dude man he's a good
dude i like you you have to do that
what's up with you tarzan we're going to
kettlebells tomorrow oh yeah you're
staying for jiu jitsu we're going to
bust it we're going what the hell is
going to kill us let's do it let's
[ __ ] go i got [ __ ] [ __ ] i got to take
head shots on wednesday stupid [ __ ] yeah
i'm going in and out all right
you
[ __ ] won't get real okay we're three
fat guys you're going to talk about
workout sessions now
we've been talking about [ __ ]
breaking bad that's why
i just thought about
[ __ ] that's what i did [ __ ] it
[ __ ] breaking them about the best bro he
wants me to flip over my back i can't do
it i i've never in my life been able to
do it he's like i'll just do it i'm like
can't it's never going to happen
who gives a [ __ ] you go then you do the
best you can don't worry about doing
that oh you can't do something i can't
do something no i know i'm just easy
okay
i can't believe i can join this
conversation but i can actually and be
relevant
holy [ __ ] okay i've been trying to
limber up and and like because traveling
so much it hurts and so my doctor as
part of i i broke my wrist and said you
know as part of my physical therapy go
to yoga okay so i'm having this
one-on-one with his yoga structure okay
i am i'm going down and i got my legs
spread as far as i can and the [ __ ]
yoga mat split in the middle
and my balls hit the [ __ ] floor and i
almost passed the [ __ ] out
my [ __ ] thighs have been
killing me for three weeks dude i swear
to god i did the full splits like i was
trying to block a goal it was the woods
oh you ripped your hair oh my god dude i
think i ripped my groin muscles all this
[ __ ] i ripped that yoga mat right down
the [ __ ] middle go
you're the first person to have said
that dude because it's so embarrassing
but those [ __ ] will rip if you get
[ __ ] 450 splitting it oh jack i
busted my ass
it took me so long to be able to get up
i didn't even know what to do i did the
instructor just pushed me back on my
back
and it eased up but oh my god but one of
the worst things i've ever had in me was
when i drowned at the ymca that time
as a fat guy that was never
more embarrassed in my [ __ ] life man
i've done some [ __ ] up [ __ ] as a fat
guy
and i don't you know you get embarrassed
about being fat you can't fat change me
but the time i almost drowned at the
wiley
[ __ ] me up i didn't say nothing for
like two months
i didn't say none i just snorted coke
and tried to hide it and [ __ ]
that was embarrassing though
i was just starting to lose weight
things were going great for me i lost
like eight pounds i was still snorting
blow i was doing big blow
and i [ __ ]
got up one morning and terry went to
work and i always slept
and i said [ __ ] i gotta swim
and i went over to the wine the y is
packed i used to go to the fat man pool
it's this little russian pool
right it was like four feet but it was
96 degrees so it's like a therapeutic
pool and i would walk around and then if
there was nobody in that would do laps
and then you could it's short laps and
nobody would see you if you go to the
big pool leave there's kids and people
see you and there's lifeguards i was
still too embarrassed i'm not going to
be a fat guy who wears a t-shirt in the
pool no
i am i'm a hot mess you don't want to
see me
i
lee i was 400 pounds
there was fat everywhere lee
and i'd sit in the sauna and i'd make
blue like i was losing weight in the sun
then i'd go on the steam bath then i
jump in the pool and i do this every
morning at 5 00 a.m
i did this to start off but i was still
snorting blow so in my mind if i ate
sushi and i went to the steam room i
would sweat the cocaine out i wasn't a
fiend no more
so now it's two in the afternoon lee i
go across the street to the y i'm still
a little hungover on the blow
and the [ __ ] steam pool is packed
with with kids jumping up and down
and i'm like i can't do my [ __ ] laps
but the adult pool the lap pool
was wide open
oh [ __ ]
i go [ __ ] this i swam when i lived in
boulder
i've been swimming for three weeks i'm
ready for the big [ __ ] pool why am i
swimming with these [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
for
i went over i put my name on the
blackboard guys i put my goggles in
and on the deep end i jumped
just the the cold water hitting me bro
it just shocked my body just shocked my
fat little body
and then i'm trying to swim i'm swimming
i'm putting everything i can i'm turning
my head i'm remembering my form
and i look up lee and i haven't even
moved like five feet i'm [ __ ]
sideways but by this time i'm out of air
like i was smoking two or three packs of
cigarettes a day i'm dying
i'm 10 feet out
but i can't swim back and my feet can't
take it so i'm just holding onto the
rope and people are swimming by me
they're going come on let go of the rope
come on swim and i'm like guys i'm dying
i'm trying to get the the shortest
distance was this way
if i swam vertically to the [ __ ] wall
i'd never make it
so i had to swim this way so i pulled
myself like spider-man
and i get to the wall and i'm huffing
and puffing guys i mean guy guys i was
[ __ ] up seriously that's when i
realized this has to end and i'm holding
on to this and i can't kick no more and
i'm out of oxygen and i'm holding on and
i got my [ __ ] chin on the thing just
holding me
and some kids are like mr mister are you
okay and i'm like no i'm not okay help
me no i come on pull them out and all
these little kids get to get these
little mexican kids and they're trying
to pull me out and they can't pull me
out they're like one two three pull and
they're pulling i'm like and i'm turning
purpley
i mean lee
i'm not breathing i'm i don't even know
about breathing through my nose i'm
starting to panic
people are starting to circle and look
around
and these little kids can't pull me on
they're like [ __ ] it ring the buzzer and
they ring this buzzer and it's going all
right
right
right
and awesome this chick gets on the thing
and she turns
this thing around and they're actually
gonna make me
listen to this they couldn't get me out
so they were going to [ __ ] drop a
hoist
into the pool and they wanted me to swim
into it and then they were going to pull
me out like a [ __ ] whale like orca
and by this time there's 50 people
watching me
you have any ideally how embarrassing
that is i got tits they're by my stomach
lee i'm purple and they're like swim to
the middle
get to the middle get to the middle and
go in and we'll drop the hoist
and the hoist will pull you out and then
we'll bring you to the side leave by
that point i'm so [ __ ] embarrassed
and now out of the corner of my eye i
see ambulance tech workers
running in with a [ __ ] mattress like
i got shot in vietnam
and something made me put my fat little
foot over
i just went
and my fat foot got over the dog
oh my god that thigh must have weighed a
thousand pounds
and i [ __ ] pulled myself up and i
rolled down like orca i just rolled down
to the pool i got up and i got up right
in time as i went through the [ __ ]
door the three ambulance workers were
running in they're like where is he like
that's him and i just walked right past
him dog because rule number one don't
stop and don't sign nothing you don't
need to get checked out mind your
business you're fine you know as long as
you get to your car i gotta be honest
with you i think there's a thing called
secondary drowning look it up lee
it happens
you just take a little bit of air i mean
a little bit of water in your nose and
it gets down your actual windpipe and it
can be a very small amount you don't
have to have this deep long
thing it's a secondary drowning look it
up lee explain it
i believe that's what it is that's what
i thought you have because i swim all
the time man you know we belong to that
tennis club i keep on inviting you to
come up there like regular white people
and let's have a goddamn party okay
you've been down eight days of [ __ ]
years i'm calling that out let's go okay
i can't go tomorrow
all right next summer no
next summer stop stop come on we got the
whole holidays you're [ __ ] we got the
holidays coming i'm going to be smoking
turkeys
i'm trying i'm trying i got okay if you
continue me all right uh trust me
i got problems okay we all got [ __ ]
yeah i'm [ __ ] jay-z over here but i
got a hundred all right no problem we
all got problems word of that
but you know what she's
[ __ ] being so great it's like it's so
like freeing for both of us and i still
love her i'm in love with her
i love my babies and that's why you know
this wasn't an acid trip night you know
what i mean it could have been but it
just simply wasn't i got real [ __ ] to do
tomorrow you know i got i've got two
beautiful babies that love their daddy
and
i i've been getting so much [ __ ] you
know about the me and the wife filing
for divorce truth was she was just
responding they only checked la records
she was already
had had i had filed on her
like
10 days before
okay
and and
so there was going to be this big
jurisdictional battle then my lawyer in
tennessee goes you know you're gonna
spend about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars just fighting over what state
we're gonna have the divorce in okay not
counting my money all right i'm supposed
to write a retainer tomorrow if she
wanted to go to war for like fifty
thousand dollars okay it's [ __ ] all
right and we're just being cool it's
like
my babies i always want them supported
my wife will never want for anything
she'll have the house that she designed
okay and she can be free and and a
miserable person to [ __ ] live with
not that i'm a fat piece of [ __ ] it's
i'm work all the [ __ ] time i'm always
and i've got babies that have to be in
school but since this [ __ ] broke on the
internet man they [ __ ] they had
people taking pictures of my kids man
it's like [ __ ] um
i'm the guy
you know what i mean it's like i'm the
guy behind the microphone you know those
are my babies
and they're just being [ __ ] dicks you
know i couldn't even go hardly
trick-or-treating with them but people
all [ __ ] up in my business so i never
even knew i wanted to slap so many
[ __ ] i just i couldn't take it
i just sat down because everybody knows
my [ __ ] business but they also know
my babies and they go yeah their parents
you know and everybody up there is
either swinging [ __ ] divorce
[ __ ] somebody else or doing coke you
know there ain't no innocent ones over
there but they're throwing stones but
man they're coming
let me ask you a question yeah you told
me a story that was [ __ ] hysterical
and i didn't understand it because
you're a funny [ __ ] dude whatever's
going on in your life right now ralphie
with your children the people from the
church we love you in there i know we
got your back we want you to know one
thing divorce ain't easy there's two
ways you could do this you want to do
this with shotguns and jews no or you
want to do this yeah and that's the way
you gotta do it because you have a
career yeah and
you want peace of mind you want peace
i'm in love with her listen man
sometimes
sometimes people try i'm thinking about
wrestling what i didn't know i don't
know anything guys i don't know anything
i just found out that these people broke
up and she's dating a new dude who who
when does this happen
how does this happen
the singer from no doubt
she's great stefanie yeah she's dating
the judge from [ __ ] the show or
something he broke up with his wife and
she broke up with her husband after 14
[ __ ] years
and and they had like a thing today like
uh
that's true
yeah yeah you know listen man people in
life sometimes don't get i pray every
day that terry stays in love with in
love with me
and i keep it together with her i pray
every day because i know how quick you
could go and the longer you're with a
person the harder it [ __ ] is and when
you have children it's even [ __ ]
harder so hard there's two ways to do a
divorce you could either a go to go to
war or b
take a [ __ ] few lumps in the head
which you're gonna take anyway okay
that's awesome you're gonna take anyway
i've taken that my whole life but ain't
no big deal either 10 people could hold
you down and put a big black dick in
your ass or you could just take a
[ __ ] white flag get naked put it on
your back turn around loop your own
[ __ ] and let them do what the [ __ ]
you gotta do okay
you know what a dick in the ass hurts
both ways but i'll tell you what it
hurts more if you clench it up
she didn't do nothing wrong and you know
what um she did help me in my career you
know the truth is when i got last comic
standing okay jay moore [ __ ] called
me on thursday go hey i need you for an
audition i was in hawaii working at the
lab factory and he said uh come back i
need you here on saturday and i looked
online and the cheapest ticket for round
trip because it still had to finish at
the in hawaii there's nobody on that
[ __ ] island who could have done it
all right and so i had to come back and
and i the the ticket was like eleven
hundred dollars
you know and
i that was that was two months rent man
that's real [ __ ] [ __ ] like for uh for
a maybe for a big [ __ ] maybe
and and i i rode the dice and i couldn't
afford it lana had a credit card that
her mama gave her for insurance and she
put it all on there
and that's what launched my whole career
so does she get half yes [ __ ]
she gets half
okay
she should get more than half she's
going to be drawing a salary from my
place you're going to be getting out of
mona like a regular white people because
we're your jews you got to respect all
right my babies already have big things
set up for them they'll never want for
anything they'll never have
what what i went through you know and
it's like that's what you want that's
true but now they're coming it's just so
irritating it's like you know they're
just dumb these [ __ ]
you know the internet is a good thing
and a bad thing yeah right the internet
is a good thing and a bad thing
you know i use the internet for certain
things i see people use it for other
things and that's fine that's what the
internet is it's your expression
but sometimes if you open up your life
on the on the internet
the result isn't going to be good it's
happened to me it's backfired yeah but
in this situation with divorce and stuff
who knows
you know
nothing to happen yet keep doing what
you're doing yeah try to put the pieces
together try uh be a father that's this
listen
the divorce in my life had to be tougher
than a prison sentence
i lost a child in a divorce i lost
dignity in the divorce
and
to this day i have animosity i haven't i
know that
i'm like michael douglas and st was the
movie when he just snapped on the 405
walking tall standing tall when he
started shooting people yeah
last straw when i saw that movie that
movie really scared me
why you ever said a movie where he goes
nuts on the phone yeah he's lost his job
the drug dealer goes to mugham and
austin he shoots him and he goes you
want my briefcase he's pretty funny in
there and now duval is looking from it's
a it's a cliche-type movie but i always
saw that happening to me with my ex-wife
that's how bad of a divorce it was i
forgave my stepfather
till this day i talked to old school
cubans and they always say [ __ ] him he
never gave you what was coming to you
you know what so then i gotta go get
what was coming to me that was my frame
of thought back then he didn't give me
my mother's money what do you want me
the only issue for three years i lived
with that i was preparing to hide under
a car and grab his foot and shoot him
where's his money now so i shoot him and
kill him how am i gonna get his money
now so i had a terrible idea
and i hated them for [ __ ] years and
one day i go what this is the guy that
raised me
would you give me three hundred thousand
dollars what was i gonna do with it was
i gonna invest was i gonna buy a
building on if i was dead i was gonna
buy coca plants off some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah so in a way he saved my [ __ ]
life you know so i forgave him over the
years and i forgave him that was it when
he died i didn't go to the funeral i
sent flowers and i went to see his wife
and then she died but i let it go i let
it go i got to tell you something
i had yeah i don't have any anger i
don't have i have but i have right now
you don't have no i know
right now i've already seen all the
numbers no i just love my babies i have
to get another
listen it has nothing to do with numbers
okay
there's there's levels of a divorce when
she walked out of the house she goes
listen
i'm just going to be a mile up the road
you come over anytime you want let me
just get some space
and i was cool with that
i'm like looking at it going
this is a dream come true i could work
on comedy
i wanted to be a [ __ ] comedian i just
got out of prison i was doing the
working stiff stuff and i go [ __ ] it
i want to do [ __ ] comedy
and all of a sudden it went from one
thing to another i hope it doesn't go
there for you
i hope you handle it no but truly i love
my babies i love my wife i hope that
the attorneys don't get a hold of this
and turn it into something else they're
not i hope that because that's when it
gets that's what happened with me yeah
once attorney's getting illegal and once
the fine print there's a fine print and
once that fine print comes out lisa yeah
they know coming back
and that fine print has to exist
it has to exist the law says it has to
exist and sometimes that
hurts
you know so you know you have our love
you have my love always i call you every
day hang on i know i send you videos of
a little spanish guy oh you gotta knock
it out get that man
it's like i'm the real deal i've been
through a divorce i've been through a
separation guys it is brutal i always
advise people if you keep it together
keep it together well no i disagree but
if there's no love there's no love no
there's no love there's no love you have
love no no this is something we
have so much love for each other but
it's like here's the real deal okay
i
uh have really [ __ ] bad ptsd
and and now i'm properly medicated by
probably the best he's the head of
psychiatry vanderbilt he's [ __ ]
amazing he's got me chemically dialed in
i sleep eight hours i'm up i don't take
naps i walk i feel great he's done it
all he's [ __ ] amazing all right but
before i got properly medicated i was a
[ __ ]
nut and a complete [ __ ] okay it you
know what you do after two years
with the elvis glasses you started to
worry me that day
what question did you have over there no
it's not a question but it was just my
my parents got divorced when i was in
high school and i actually had wish they
got divorced earlier like they said like
we stayed together
because the kids i
i even back then
even back then i thought i loved you it
would be better just to have like you're
just a tough dude this is uh
you know i was listening man
i feel
last comic standing is a great show and
uh and it shows a lot of comics to the
country and a lot of vice versa i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm saying
when ralphie was on last comic standing
he was already a brilliant headliner
ralph was already had a lot of people
paying tickets to go see him i mean
this just accelerated
the program where now these kids become
somebody ralphie may was already
somebody
you you following me ralphie was already
somebody
it
went from one thing to one thing ralphie
i judged it i was there i was there when
we were when when you were
you know cooking for us with no money
and also next thing you know we're
sitting on wilshire boulevard with a jar
of weed in the living room and people
just stick in their hands and taking
weed to go and he knew it he didn't give
a [ __ ] take it that's what showing
around
the [ __ ] whole thing yeah i mean
every time he'd seen me give me 200
bucks
to do what you do
it's hard
on a person never mind on the marriage
yeah this has been a journey for you and
you've learned and now
i hope that you keep it together and
yeah
much more peace
in my life i've got so much less stress
and less anxiety
i i don't have nightmares every night
now with the ptsd from spellbinders no
no no that's hilarious you see the
bottom line
hey that was 12k shut your mouth
[ __ ] that was a good angle all
right i broke my [ __ ] ball but hey i
[ __ ] got 12k out of it worked to the
mother no it's when i had a bilateral
double pneumonia pulmonary embolism and
i had to stay awake for nine days
uh because if they said if i couldn't
help my lungs expand
i would die
and
i had the blood clot was so big
that um because i had pneumonia and i'd
broken two ribs and from coughing and
that's what caused the blood clot to go
right it was right here and
they said that a radiologist was going
to come in at 7 00 a.m and enter this uh
this vein and go into that and find it
right there by the lung and he goes you
have to be awake we can't give you any
anesthesia and it's inside you it's it's
[ __ ] it [ __ ] hurts in there man all
right
and and uh
that that they're gonna you got a five
percent chance of living okay if it if
it if it [ __ ] if it blows the clot
out
okay
you you [ __ ] live and if not you'll
bleed out in your brain and you'll have
a stroke good luck hey sleep tight
boom [ __ ] i was [ __ ] up jack
that [ __ ] snap that snapped your
[ __ ] head dude and so what i've been
doing i've been doing like a lot of ptsd
groups okay and they're always like what
the [ __ ] are you doing here and i'm like
look here [ __ ] uh i'm just as
[ __ ] up as you are and let's get to
the real deal let's talk about some [ __ ]
well like you even know about i mean you
know how many times i've gone overseas
for the [ __ ] military like 19 i'm in
a 44 ford operating bases in multiple
war zones okay by the way afghanistan
this time of year is [ __ ] beautiful
all the talibans turbines change colors
it's like those dirty [ __ ]
little hey reds and yellows it's
beautiful okay but i've been there and
then they start getting real dude and
man and those guys get real it gets real
real you know i mean it's like i know it
sounds stupid right but you're
absolutely right
you know ralphie man i gotta tell you
i'm sitting across from you
i'm gonna end this podcast in a couple
minutes but i gotta tell you something
it's uh
i'm 52 man i've had a great life i laugh
i love
thinking of being upset and laughing i
live to laugh people
i know sometimes i come across as a
prick i love giggling i love laughing
i have a lot of regrets in my life i did
a lot of [ __ ] up things i was talking
about my godfather before
one of the biggest regrets i have
that we didn't have the money to do
ralphie
what a mistake that
what a mistake that we could go back and
rewire
that apartment with a camera oh my god
we would have a show and i'm telling you
that would have been the all time it
would be hbo's all-time greatest comedy
show and you can't and you know when i'm
sitting here across from my mouth and
i'm listening to a story and i'm like
i can't even go to hbo like i'm talking
i'm taking a ralphy narrating a show
about adventures of a fat guy
and just even all that stuff the tube
when you fell that time oh falling on
gardner listen i'm sitting here crossing
you
and i'm like okay not even guarding the
thing you were telling lee about that
he's going on you don't understand
this chick
he's this chick is living in his house
before we're talking about the story
here's three guys trying to [ __ ] the
same trick
it's miserable chris i'm the only one
not trying to [ __ ] her but you wanted to
[ __ ] if your face fell into the [ __ ]
it wouldn't be
it wouldn't have been the worst it
wouldn't have been a birthday
so something happened they're having an
argument you cannot write this lisa yet
this is an apartment that's living on
whatever round for you society yeah i'm
living off ralphie i got a little bit of
coke in my pocket ralphie's making
bloody mary's
bloody mary's and we're going over there
we're hitting this every night what red
dead everybody knew that at two in the
morning after the coast of the party
my apartment the red devil ricky cruz
babaloo
you know and we just talked
somebody would have a joint somebody
wouldn't have a joint but this one night
it was just me there we are we're
drinking bloody marys and we're giggling
and jody says something to ralphie to
piss him off
and there was a big japanese lamp in the
kitchen
all right and [ __ ] oh he sits down and
she pisses him off
and he sits in the position and
something happened that the light got a
little lower and he's [ __ ] saying
[ __ ] to her with his face red right he's
like [ __ ] you this is my house
don't you ever talk to me like this this
is my [ __ ] house you believe this
coco she's my guest and she's talking to
me like this this is my vodka or
something and he in the middle of his
rage he's like ah and he stops because
the light bulb is burning his head
invert my hair you can't write that you
cannot write that that's inspector cruzo
type
you busted that toilet in your house
don't no no no it was javascript
you
and you also [ __ ] and give a shower and
then push it down with your toe
[ __ ] okay i know the real
you coco all right you can [ __ ] with
these other [ __ ] but i'm bona fide
okay i was there at the beginning okay
lighten the bum on fire
eating people's [ __ ] if that apartment
building
had a [ __ ] camera oh my god we would
be
multi millions of millionaires i tell
the story of the night i brought shamer
there and she was giving these people uh
drug dealers one of the [ __ ] shamers oh
so i left it downstairs in gavin's
apartment gavin and the armenian oh
she's dancing and she's dancing and
telling the espn story and i come back
at five and there's one guy
horrible and impressive
yeah
oh my god
horrible
oh my god and this disney [ __ ] like
breaks out into like joe pesci
yeah whatever [ __ ] take them titties
i love to i always love one i still talk
to him when i go to vegas
is she in vegas now
that's awesome she is so
good she opens for everybody she's got a
little gig she's
she dances at a [ __ ] lesbian bar but
she keeps marrying gay guys by mistake
what she hooked up with that dude in
alaska i had to do this what listen to
me about 15 years ago i got to do this
again you made a game listen to me i had
to do this gig in alaska one time
at chicago and at one of those for one
of those people and i canceled i got
like the stupid tv show or something for
mbc and i had a cancer and she went up
there and met a uh a go-go dance like a
a
a male dancer and they fell in love and
she put me down and she put his name on
her little [ __ ]
and then whoa back to l.a and they were
in love man that's he was like he was
like unemployed but he always came up a
little bit of money and she was dating
him like two years they were in love and
then one day
she wanted his email she saw an email
from old dudes that would he would go to
their house in the afternoon and put
like a bikini and he would dance for old
dudes and [ __ ] and he would get like 50
bucks and do meth
so she threw a mountain she was
heartbroken because she always makes
[ __ ] up choices i've told this story
before this is hilarious
somebody tells me this is the this is
the name of the guy that she's got on
her [ __ ] this guy is a go-go dancer for
old dudes and he's smoking meth so she
throws them
holy [ __ ] she's closing out i hear about
this about a month later right now no no
no
i bump into her
and she says to me how are you doing
we're going back and forth
and i go hey
and i knew that i don't know what the
guy's name was beat on me so how's mark
doing and she gets kind of sad she goes
i'm not with mark anymore
that's a shame i go listen
i know this old dude
either way
you gotta give it up to her
she is a queen of a ball buster she will
give it but she will [ __ ] take it i
tell you what she takes it better than a
lot of [ __ ] bonified grown man she's
always that well she seems [ __ ] funny
she came up at the commission
[ __ ] comedy
her mother's a biker her mother's gemma
did you know that her mother's like
gemma like she was telling me stories
showing me pictures one time in the
house her mother's like gemma
and she's half arab
i didn't know that yeah she's an arabian
she's like uh jesus irene
she's beautiful i tell you if you could
you think that she had plastic surgery
and you're like but you realize it's
just natural she blows her and april
mesa used to be real [ __ ] tight
two pieces of ass hanging out together
this is 12 15 years ago they're going
doing this dirty shows all over the
place and they started doing armed
forces show they got a my f my face what
was before twitter and my space myspace
they got a myspace page together and
they would do all these dirty rooms and
they got a penthouse to pay them peanuts
but they had something going on in vegas
they were really trying
and every time you'd see one you'd see
the other
and one day i see shane and i go what's
going on where's your buddy she goes we
don't talk no more so in the back of my
mind i'm like wow wow
it's two girls they went for the same
guy it's some girl [ __ ] about a month
later i find that
they're on a trip back from the [ __ ]
ends
sarah tiana verified it
they're on a plane on the way back and
often the plane says have an engine
trouble and they're going to die
the plane's going to go down and also
they we're going to release the mass and
they release the mass but only one came
down it was sheamus mess [ __ ] april
macy took and held it down started
choking
the [ __ ]
that's deep
that's savagery comedy [ __ ] right there
ralphie man
are you still today are you still on the
netflix tour
yes unruly uh we've got uh we've got the
west coast uh this uh this whole month
over the next two weeks and then you
know it's the lord's day is thanksgiving
you got to give back to grace all right
uh i'm going i'm hitting uh eugene um
i got
santa cruz uh
fresno
holy [ __ ] look how high horn over there
i don't know what i am on but man this
is great
seattle look at the flying jew oh he is
[ __ ] in zuma land jesus
christ hello oh
all the church members up in canada
first time i'm coming to vancouver man
come out here yeah let's go see him
that's the [ __ ] town that's a town
jack i heard a lot of great things
they're going to carry out to the bus
oh my god
oh my god no no that's a [ __ ] up dude
i had to go through utah those [ __ ]
suckers the the cops searched me those
[ __ ] asked me if i did cocaine
i'm like the fact that i'm this fat i
can talk to you proves i cannot do
cocaine i've never done it okay and then
then the guy asked me if i want some
quail you buy my own quaaludes and i'm
like what the [ __ ] here is this 77
yeah thought yeah can i buy quaaludes
from you uh and well give me 20 [ __ ]
grams of triceratops horn you dumb [ __ ]
it's there's nothing there you know what
the official quote was the one i gave
them because i i was [ __ ] up you know
what i was [ __ ] up on cold medicine i
had a sinus infection because i just
come from a goddamn disney cruise with
my kids okay we flew to the [ __ ] we
were in the bahamas and i was on that
[ __ ] pool i mean that boat of germs
okay and i got and then i went to flew
to denver so i went from 82 to 12. okay
[ __ ] me all right i had all this [ __ ] in
my head and oh it was horrible so i
started off with like all the dayquil
stuffs okay
like [ __ ]
just like dayquil theraflu day
okay like every muse the next day every
day [ __ ] they had and and i dry it up a
little bit i wouldn't have boogers
coming out of my head okay
all right this is the real deal okay
all right all right but i started
shaking
i'm shaking i started shaking cause i'm
all [ __ ] up on all that cold medicine
so okay coco i'm not gonna [ __ ] you
i i got the night quilt out you know i'm
trying to smooth this ride out you know
i'm trying to try to [ __ ] meddle this
train and then i just take a big old
swallower
[ __ ] a [ __ ] nyquil really
it wasn't weed
i played nyquil roulette and lost okay
and you know when my wife goes she goes
do why didn't you use the measuring cup
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about measuring cup
that's that cap on the top of the
[ __ ] nyquil it's a measuring cup i've
never [ __ ] used that in my goddamn
life i didn't have no idea okay
[ __ ] i just drank enough you
know i go like it's like two shots
[ __ ] when you broke a number
hey that was your fault that was good
ass [ __ ] drugs you gave me all right
okay that was you and gravity
[ __ ] you own that okay you're a
dick and i wasn't the only one you
[ __ ] up some [ __ ] off getting out of
there
okay so you can suck a dick and by the
way we went to that jack of the box
right behind his house because we were
smelling all them [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no i didn't go to that jaguar
i had to pull over i couldn't stop
laughing
i'm [ __ ] that way
so what happened
okay okay all right
and let me finish this you [ __ ]
all right cuz i know you don't believe
me but my wife goes that's a measuring
cup and i'm like well i might be dumb
but you're a dirty [ __ ] i ain't never
seen one in a dishwasher that's just
gross you leave the same cap that's
disgusting all right and so i was just
like [ __ ] hit it but you know what i
quoted them because they were just
making lies up
about me i was like
last thing i said before i had on stage
i heard was uh uh all i said was uh yes
mr cosby i'd love another cocktail
that's all i that's all i remember all
right
and that's just like go [ __ ] yourself
you'll get [ __ ] up by michael dude let
me tell you something
hip-hop comedy stop steve harveys and
michonne mcdonald's all black
and comedy club in a hotel okay and
i i was sitting back there with these
crazy ass like i met this guy that goes
well yeah my name's willie d all right
he's really deep from the ghetto boys
okay and then this little ass [ __ ]
walks over bushwick bill okay and he's
gangster okay i mean bushwick bill was
no [ __ ] he had knives on him and
[ __ ] that little [ __ ] cut your
balls off that was eye level to him
okay
this guy named dj screw would do all
right but we drink that with seven uh
okay or mountain dew boom they do a
mountain dew so they wouldn't pass out
so he did just drink that syrup all
right and we was [ __ ] up how much
would you pour in because i only like
every time i get wrong kind of said yeah
dude they poured a lot in mine okay they
poured a lot and they [ __ ] load and a
lot of them was putting that what's that
sh
um the raspberry liqueur like chambord
or something they pour chambord in it
too so you'd have can uh you'd have uh
like grape soda with some chambord and
syrup okay and all those foods were
doing that all of them it was and and it
was like
i can't i didn't know what hit me okay
because it didn't taste like too late
and i was like what and they call me up
on stage and for whatever reason it was
the greatest set of the four years i've
ever done comedy
and and i relax yeah but i was you know
i've been smoking weed in the back with
this little crazy [ __ ] passing it
because it was so funny to look at a
[ __ ] when you're on coding and smoking
weed and and and like if the [ __ ]
takes the joint out of your hand but it
looks so much infinitely bigger in his
hand than it ever did in yours it's
crazy
like what whoa
okay it's amazing but
i i came in and blew the place apart got
a standing ovation all right but a guy a
comic came on stage who hated my [ __ ]
guts that he was like he was trying to
be like the number one guy and he had
tried to do everything and i blew the
guy out of the [ __ ] water steve
harvey told me i did okay it was
everybody was [ __ ] unanimous and he
starts talking [ __ ] about me being fat
like making all these fat [ __ ] jokes and
the audience turns on the guy and then
out of nowhere you see this nickel
45 1911 45 caliber come up and go
and it is bushwick bill and he goes
bring the fat white boy back shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] all right and he was about
to shoot that man okay because that's
that's how gangster and [ __ ] up this
guy was and and they was like okay i'm
gonna [ __ ] it uh okay where are we i had
nothing [ __ ] left
what the [ __ ] what how can you follow
what you just did i had nothing at all
i'm like oh
oh man i love those midgets you know
they always they've always got you back
up to here all right and i got the [ __ ]
out i was so scared i'm like this he's
already pulled a gun once he's going to
shoot me for making a [ __ ] joke at him
but he loved it because he was all
[ __ ] up and fallen over and [ __ ] it
was crazy man midgets when they
pass out they just kind of like you know
weeble wobbles and then then they go
okay there's
okay you never hung out with no men just
like that [ __ ] all they created
i like them i like them they're good
people
get the [ __ ] out of here word to that
great church by the way thank you for
having me coach is getting [ __ ] up on
call i want to drink what black people
are drinking now i saw it on drugs inc
what was it what is it that [ __ ] they
drinking memphis and this what is it
it's like a liquid coating and they mix
it with kool-aid oh yeah
yeah
yeah that's the exact same thing
it's just you mix coding with a drink no
you what you do is you get it's cough
syrup it's cough syrup and and from i
remember [ __ ] up on that stuff well
you know i drank nightfall as a kid as a
kid i had discovered nyquil when i was
like nine i remember they would help you
fall asleep oh so i liked it but i
didn't like the feeling in the morning
i've never chugged codeine but
it's great just to have a it's like it's
like a joint
it's like a pills get my i'm
dude i get i get i get i get so
[ __ ] i can't eat that [ __ ]
no my [ __ ] little pooper gets worn
out i can't [ __ ] and it's miserable [ __ ]
that i don't do none of that [ __ ]
anymore man drink something like cough
medicine and [ __ ] one night though you
don't want to record some [ __ ] oh man
that's what we used to do play slow the
horse in this [ __ ] one time
bring it back bring the horse in this
[ __ ] one time hey lee lee put
this song on okay this is a great song
hold on we got to get the [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] out of here where did that
let's do this real quick
for 9 000 years that's how long humans
been making wine that's also how long
they've been confused about which wine
to drink some people get a headache
after they drink wine i used to get a
headache one time i shoplifted a bottle
of wine from albertsons and across my
hudson county park and i drank it with
diddy cantero and louis castle you know
i had a headache for two [ __ ] days
but for many of us it's a shopping part
that causes a real headache you got too
many choices you don't you don't know
what to do people are coming over
they're serving chicken they're serving
lobster and sometimes you go down there
and wine's expensive you went in there
to buy a 20. next you know you're
dropping 60 and you got no guarantee of
what you're gonna buy right let me tell
you something it's overwhelming to pick
out a good bottle of wine sometimes
especially for people who don't know it
your own personal experience learning
about wine and why haven't you about to
learn about wine that type of stuff this
is what we're gonna do i joined the new
wine club it's called club w
they change the whole game it's easy you
go to club w dot com and you answer six
questions the algorithm grim whatever
your salary algorithm algorithm creates
a palette profile just for you i don't
know where the card is right now it's
pretty cool man if you ever seen
anything like this club w is leading the
glass the grape to glass wine revolution
what it means is they cut out the
middleman they work directly for the
vineyards and they cut the guy out which
in turn saves you some do re me so with
club w's you get premium wine customized
to your taste at a third of what you pay
for at a store when you don't even know
what the hell you're paying for yeah
you're not with me you're not buying
like it's not like a club where they
send you other companies wines these are
their wines like you're not gonna see
these ones anywhere else but the most
interesting thing is going to their
webpage when you go to clubw.com
you go on their page and have all these
videos informative videos and they tell
you what wines to drink you take the
test and next thing you know you're
involved
which when you don't know about that
listen man i grew up in a bar i don't
know nothing about wine so when i went
to club w i was blown away by how much
interaction you have they'll put it down
to the exact thing i mean the nut the
grape where it came from the vineyard
anyway what they do is they save you
money it comes down to maybe thirteen
dollars a bottle of wine or something
like that and there's even a no risk 100
guarantee that you'll love when they
send you so do me a favor right now what
what what they're doing is for all the
listeners is they're offering 50 off
your first order when you go to club w
dot com slash joey
so do you understand me
50 off your first order when you go to
club w dot com slash joey and this is
not like [ __ ] columbia house where
they send you records every month even
if you don't want them no you order what
you want right so if you think you need
three bottles you order three bottles
it's 13 a bottle they get delivered to
your door and it's exactly what you like
what you're guaranteed to love or you
get 100 money back guaranteed so again
do me a favor you get 50 off your first
order go to club w dot com slash joey
stop wasting time and stop losing money
at these retail stores and start
drinking wine you know you're gonna love
so go to club w dot com slash joey to
get your 50 off all right i'm doing it
just to get this
to thanksgiving parties you were born
no but i'm just saying like let's say
you have to bring stuff to a party yeah
man just get through just get three
bottles of wine and then you're gonna
have to go to at least this town takes
the whole week off
you there's parties every night we're
off until the start of the new year now
when i used to work on tv a little bit
of work not really
yeah until then now until thanksgiving
it's gonna be busy
but then after that it's they're out
everybody's skiing
yep that's good to know
anyway let me tell you something i tell
you once i'm going into a heavy season
now
i go into like six weeks of flying
so this whole thing dog i got my on it i
always slam without them what's the one
i take the immune the shroom tech immune
let me tell you something those planes
are filthy
those planes are filthy
if you think you get off a plane they
steam it with chemicals and they wipe
down nothing
in my bag there's a [ __ ] deodorizer i
got a hand sanitizer to wipe everything
that's the first thing i do when i sit
down now i don't want somebody else's
ass on my ass then i'm stinking like
that [ __ ] ass you gotta wipe those
[ __ ] seats down
so do me a fa it's just bad when you fly
there's a lot of human contact this time
of the year do yourself a favor go to
honor.com get the shroom tech immune you
boost up your immune system and you have
a lot of human contact when you're
flying we're out we're smoking dope with
different people you hit a vapor pen you
know
you get sick this time of year you lose
[ __ ] thousands of dollars especially
you ralphy man i can't afford to [ __ ]
get sick i can't so i i don't take a
chance i up my vitamin c when i fly and
i also take shroom tech immune but that
that's not only the only thing [ __ ]
on it's got they got shroom tech sport
which gives you more endurance when you
roll lift weights walk whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do even when you fly it
opens you up they have strong bone they
have the hemp protein powder and they
got alpha brand you know it's an end
with 100 100 money back guarantee the
nootropics that it's off the [ __ ]
charts so do yourself a favor go to
island.com right now and press in church
boom and get 10 off your first order and
if you get it sent right to your [ __ ]
door you have to leave the house you
have to go to whole foods you have to do
nothing what are you pressing lee church
beautiful number two 86.com what'd your
dad say he loves him he says that
because we say it's five for 50.
it's half off they're usually 20 they
you know because it's usually like 20
bucks they're 20 a piece you get right
now 86 tremendous 1200 guaranteed puffs
right here i'm smoking the reefer but
right here my little [ __ ] cigar here
i'm living like a doctor i'm like pacino
and godfather too you just don't even
[ __ ] know it
you broke my heart
86.com right now they got the tobacco
they got the cigar all right then they
have the tobacco a cigarette line it's
24 16 8 and 0 milligrams some nicotine
you quit smoking with it whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do my dad likes the
flavors
and the flavors you could switch it up
go to h86.com and press in joey's church
boom and get five for fifty which is
fifty percent off
nailed it life.com the vapor kings you
want a vapor pen you like smoking you
like doing this you want to see the
devil
go to nail the life dot com right now
whatever they run only tell them
when you use cobra joey diaz you're
gonna get 20 off the premier vapor pan
on the market for all the oil and wax
smokers out there
and if you live in california they are
also the makers of those commissioners
there you go
so listen do yourself a favor please
support nailed the life please support
haiti six please support honor and
please go to club w it's a holiday
season it's beautiful wine delivered to
your door that's perfect for you i'm
here to save you guys money i'm not
trying to [ __ ] sell you no junk or
not like that don't forget my main man
is where the nokia dealer i'm at this
friday
night go to ralphiemaid.com yes for
tickets go to ralphmay.com for
everything go see if he's coming to your
[ __ ] neighborhood i'll pray there
soon i don't want to miss this [ __ ] i
go everywhere i'm in portland thursday
through sunday and i'm in new jersey
next week at the stress factor all right
guys hey i love that club man and maybe
those boys and recorders come out man i
like those guys and thank you for coming
on we gotta go hey church you know what
that's [ __ ] me yeah i'm sorry it's
[ __ ] up coco you know there's cameras
and microphones here but at the base of
it it's it's back 16 17 years 1440 me
and you my little glass table sitting by
the window you know cracking [ __ ]
jokes cracking [ __ ] just only leaves
here that's it haley
yeah how are you feeling
we've ever had
i'm uh i'm good and that's when that's
what coco brought up the church of
what's happening now made me a deacon
okay you've been there you've been right
there with us 15 years ago i'm pregnant
[ __ ] gumbo
close it up thank you roughly for coming
on don't forget i love you friday night
i love you [ __ ] i love you thank
you sir and thank you all for having me
on i really appreciate if you stuck
around and i know i get long-winded and
i'm i'm annoying when i laugh so i
apologize if i look but but i love him
and it makes me cry laughing so i'm
sorry
bye
so people love you on the show
oh that's so nice
this show was brought to you by club w
go to club w dot com slash joey to get
50 off of your first
order you're gonna that's right go to
clubw.comw.com
to get 50 off
your of your first order i'll just do
this later
what do you want to close this guys